All right, lady, you know that Lee was just shooting his movie in Oklahoma City. And the movie gave him a place to stay because he was there for months. Right. But for two of those weeks, me and the kids came out to join him and the place he was staying in that the movie provided. It was just too small to your whole family. We're a whole family. He went on Airbnb, got us the most beautiful, spacious place to stay. With the nicest host. Well you know if you're planning a trip or you're working
好吧，女士，你知道李刚刚在俄克拉荷马城拍电影。剧组给他安排了住处，因为他在那里呆了好几个月。没错。但其中有两周，我和孩子们去跟他会合，剧组给他安排的那个住处。对你们一大家子来说实在太小了。我们是一大家子人。他上了爱彼迎，给我们找了个最漂亮、最宽敞的住处。房东人也超级好。好吧，你知道的，如果你正在计划一次旅行，或者你在某个地方工作
somewhere and you want to stay at an Airbnb, I think you guys got to check out their guest favorite because those are the most loved homes on Airbnb. Oh! We were a guest favorite! We were in a guest favorite. You scared me. So sorry, it's true. You're so excited. I was. Well, yeah, I mean, you're actually getting a home other people have stayed in. Yes.
想住在爱彼迎，我觉得你们一定要去看看他们的“爱彼迎房客最爱”，因为那些是爱彼迎上最受欢迎的房源。噢！我们就是房客最爱！我们住的就是房客最爱。你吓到我了。非常抱歉，这是真的。你太兴奋了。我是挺兴奋的。好吧，对，我的意思是，你实际上是住在别人曾经住过的家里。没错。
And you know it's been well-reviewed. Well, listen, we are huge fans of Airbnb for so many reasons. So for your next adventure, consider Airbnb. Hi there, everyone. Hi there. I feel a little spring in the air. Well, you're on spring break, Angela. I know, my hydrangeas are starting to bloom.
而且你知道它评价很好。听着，我们是爱彼迎的超级粉丝，原因有很多。所以，对于你的下一次冒险，考虑一下爱彼迎吧。大家好。大家好。我感觉空气中弥漫着一丝春天的气息。安吉拉，你正在过春假呢。我知道，我的绣球花开始盛开了。
Don't even get me started. My family is on what I really believe is a well-deserved vacation. Lee has finished shooting New Year's Rev. Whoop, whoop. He is back from Oklahoma City. You know, I didn't make a big deal out of this, but I was solo parenting for like the last four months.
别跟我提这个。我的家人正在享受一个我真心觉得实至名归的假期。李已经拍完《新年倒计时》了。万岁，万岁。他从俄克拉荷马城回来了。你知道的，我没有把这当成什么大事，但在过去的四个月左右，我一直是独自带娃。
It is so nice to have him back. So anyway, everyone, we are on vacation this week, but we wanna use this opportunity to highlight a pretty cool new podcast. You guys know I am a big sports fan. I love going to sports games. I just, anyway, I just love them and I love women's sports. And that's why we are so excited to share a preview of the Women's Hoop Show, a new
能让他回来真是太好了。不管怎样，各位，我们这周在度假，但我们想借此机会向大家推荐一个非常棒的新播客。大家知道我是个铁杆体育迷。我喜欢去现场看体育比赛。总之，我就是喜欢，而且我超爱女子体育。这就是为什么我们非常兴奋地与大家分享《女子篮球秀》的精彩看点，这是一档全新的
weekly podcast about all things women's basketball. Cassie, I know you're very excited about this. That's right, Cassie. We're so excited to have you here in the studio with us to talk about this. Yeah, I listened to this show when it was Queens of the Court podcast last season. And I'm a huge women's basketball fan.
每周播客，内容涵盖女子篮球的方方面面。卡西，我知道你对此非常兴奋。没错，卡西。我们很高兴你能来到我们的录音室和我们一起聊这个话题。对，上个赛季当它还叫“球场女王”播客时我就听了。而且我是一个狂热的女篮球迷。
I'm always watching the WNBA. So every Tuesday, I'm downloading this podcast, and I'm listening to them talk about anything I might have missed or just having someone to talk about women's basketball because that's all I want to do constantly. That's so great. And this is the perfect show.
我一直在看 WNBA。所以每周二，我都下载这个播客，听他们讨论我可能错过的事情，或者只是找人聊聊女子篮球，因为这就是我一直想做的事。太棒了。这绝对是绝佳的节目。
Jordan is so fun. She's such a great host and like is on the ground for a lot of the games. And oh, that's so exciting. So is she able to give insights that you didn't maybe necessarily pick up on? Yeah. And sometimes there's like,
乔丹太有趣了。她是一位非常棒的主持人，而且经常亲临许多比赛现场。噢，太令人兴奋了。所以她能提供一些你未必能注意到的独到见解吗？对。有时候，
online, there's like shade being thrown at by the different players. Like, it's all in good fun, but sometimes I just don't see it, so. She catches you up on all of that? Yeah, yeah. Well, what I really love about it is there's a rotating cast of other women's basketball experts.
网上不同的球员之间会有点口水战。这其实都是闹着玩的，但有时我就是没注意到，所以。她能帮你补全所有这些八卦？对，对。嗯，我真正喜欢的是节目有一批轮流登场的女篮专家。
There's gonna be players, coaches, commentators, and even retired legends. Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Who are some of the guests that you've really liked? In the past, they had Courtney Williams on, who's like one of my favorite basketball players. She plays on the Minnesota Lynx right now. And she's so funny, but she was talking about how like she never envisioned herself becoming a professional basketball player. She thought she was going to join the military.
会有球员、教练、解说员，甚至退役传奇球星。是的。是的。没错。你最喜欢哪些嘉宾？过去他们请过科特尼·威廉姆斯，她是我最喜欢的篮球运动员之一。她现在效力于明尼苏达山猫队。她太搞笑了，但她谈到自己从没想过会成为一名职业篮球运动员。她原本以为自己会去参军。
And she was just playing basketball, like street basketball, and then from there, got into college, and now is like one of the best players right now in the WNBA. And I didn't know that about her. I love that. You know, Cassie, my best friend in high school was six foot three, which is hilarious because I'm five one. And she was the basketball star. She got a full ride for college on basketball.
她当时只是在打篮球，就像街头篮球那样，然后从那儿打进了大学，现在成了WNBA里最顶尖的球员之一。我以前对她并不了解。我太喜欢这个故事了。你知道吗，卡西，我高中时最好的朋友身高六尺三寸，这太搞笑了，因为我只有五尺一寸。她是篮球明星。她因为打篮球获得了大学全额奖学金。
And I just love the support and comradery of that group of women and how they lift each other up. But then they also like give you a hard time. Yeah, yeah. Well, we're gonna take a break. And when we come back, we're gonna give you an opportunity to listen to the Women's Hoops show hosted by Jordan Robinson as she dives deep into the WNBA, college hoops, and the rise of new leagues like Unrivaled.
我太喜欢那群女性之间的支持与情谊，以及她们如何互相扶持。但同时她们也会给你制造点难度。对，对。好吧，我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将为你提供一个机会，聆听由乔丹·罗宾逊主持的《女子篮球秀》，她将深入探讨WNBA、大学篮球以及诸如“无与伦比”等新兴联赛的崛起。
If you love women's basketball, this is your year-round home for the biggest stories in the game. Enjoy. Yay! Yay! Yay! Thanks Jenna and Angela for such a great intro. Hi Office Ladies listeners. I'm Jordan Robinson, the host of The Women's Hoop Show and a women's basketball journalist. I am so excited to share what a typical episode of ours sounds like.
如果你热爱女子篮球，这里就是你全天候关注这项运动最大新闻的家园。尽情享受吧。耶！耶！耶！感谢詹娜和安吉拉这么棒的介绍。嗨，办公室女士的听众们。我是乔丹·罗宾逊，《女子篮球秀》的主持人，也是一名女篮记者。我非常兴奋能和大家分享我们的一期典型节目是什么样的。
We're in the full swing of March Madness. So this is our NCAA Women's Final Four preview. If you're already a hardcore women's basketball fan, you'll love it, I promise. But if you're new, I hope you learn something and become a fan by the end. And by the way, I just rewatched my favorite episode of The Office, which was the basketball one, of course.
我们正处于疯狂三月的白热化阶段。所以这是我们的NCAA女篮四强赛前瞻。如果你已经是坚定的女篮球迷，我保证你会喜欢。但如果你是新手，我希望你能有所收获，并在最后成为粉丝。顺便说一句，我刚刚重温了我最喜欢的《办公室》剧集，当然就是打篮球那一集。
I'm a huge fan of the show. I love, love The Office. We know Stanley wouldn't be able to hold a candle to these ladies that we're about to talk about, but Phyllis, she was a baller. Throw her in the post against Lauren Betts and see what happens. I would put some money on Phyllis.
我是这部剧的超级粉丝。我太爱《办公室》了。我们都知道，斯坦利跟我们今天要聊的这些女士们相比简直差远了，但菲莉丝，她可真是个狠角色。把她放到内线对位劳伦·贝茨，看看会发生什么。我愿意押菲莉丝赢。
Okay, that's enough of me. Enjoy the show and thank you for listening. Welcome to the Women's Poop Show. Last week, I sat down with a Texas and WNBA legend, Fran Harris, to talk about her undefeated season at UT, winning the very first WNBA championship and her takes on March Madness and more. She DM'd me as soon as Texas won and said, how about the Longhorns? So make sure to go back and listen to that episode. It was so fun. But on today's show, I'm joined again by my amazing co-host, Autumn Johnson, to preview the final four. I can't believe we're here already.
好了，我废话够了。享受节目吧，谢谢你们的收听。欢迎来到《女子篮球秀》。上周，我和德克萨斯州大及WNBA的传奇人物弗兰·哈里斯坐在一起，聊了聊她在德州大学的不败赛季、赢得史上第一个WNBA总冠军，以及她对疯狂三月的看法等等。德州赢球后她立刻给我发私信说：“长角牛队怎么样？”所以一定要回头去听那一期节目。太有趣了。但在今天的节目中，我的老搭档、优秀的联合主持人奥特姆·约翰逊再次和我一起，来前瞻四强赛。真不敢相信我们这么快就到这儿了。
We'll break down the matchups, share our predictions, and we'll start by giving a big picture overall of the season and what it all means as we head into the final weekend of college basketball. Let's get into it. I can't wait. All right. Autumn, you are already in Tampa. You are already getting your mind right for the Final Four. How are you? How's your bracket doing?
我们将剖析对阵形势，分享我们的预测，首先我们将对本赛季进行宏观的总体回顾，看看在我们迎来大学篮球的最后一个周末时，这一切意味着什么。让我们切入正题。我等不及了。好的。奥特姆，你已经身在坦帕了。你已经在为四强赛调整心态了。你怎么样？你的预测晋级表怎么样？
But mostly, how are you? I'm great. I'm in Tampa. The sun is out. I mean, it's warm, great weather. The beach is near and Final four teams are coming in. I'm here already to catch up with them tomorrow, but super excited to finally be here. This is what all teams work for.
但最重要的是，你感觉如何？我很好。我在坦帕。阳光灿烂。我是说，天气温暖，好天气。海滩就在附近，四强球队也正在抵达。我今天已经在这里准备明天去见他们了，但能最终来到这里我超级兴奋。这就是所有球队努力的目标。
My bracket on the other hand, it's not too shabby. I have a majority of my teams in. I predicted South Carolina, UCLA, a Yukon as well. Just that one team, Texas, defeating, you know, just able to come into the final four. Yeah, I had Notre Dame, as we know. I said that on here, but I'm very excited of the four final teams we have. Yeah, we're gonna talk about that in Notre Dame.
另一方面，我的预测晋级表，还算马马虎虎。我预测的球队大部分都晋级了。我预测了南卡罗来纳州大、UCLA，还有康涅狄格大学。只有德克萨斯州大这一支球队打破常规，你知道的，成功杀入了四强。对，正如我们所知，我选了圣母大学。我在节目里说过，但对于我们拥有的四支决赛队伍，我感到非常兴奋。对，我们待会儿会聊到圣母大学。
We're gonna talk about that a little bit later, a little bit later. I also joined your bracket challenge, and I am in eighth right now, because we all know I went hard for the upsets in Spokane 1 and Harvard, you let me down. You let me down. You were gonna make me look like the smartest person
我们待会儿再聊那个，稍后再聊。我也加入了你的预测晋级表挑战赛，我现在排在第八位，因为我们都知道我为了斯波坎1号的冷门拼尽全力，而哈佛，你们让我失望了。你们让我失望了。你们本打算让我看起来像是
in the world. I think everyone picked Harvard though. Everyone was writing for Harvard. You're not alone. Yeah, that didn't work out. That didn't work out for me. Florida State also, I looked so great in that first half against LSU. And then I have no idea what happened in that second half.
全世界最聪明的人。不过我想大家都选了哈佛吧。大家都在支持哈佛。你并不孤单。对，那次没成功。那次对我来说没成功。还有佛罗里达州立大学，我对阵LSU的上半场我看起来太棒了。然后下半场我完全不知道发生了什么。
But it's okay. I'm sitting eighth out of 16. I haven't even checked, honestly. Not eight out of eight. No, that's all that matters. I haven't checked. Like, how am I doing? You're above me. You're above check like you're doing you're okay
但没关系。我在16个人里排名第八。说实话，我甚至都没查。不是八分之八。不，这才是最重要的。我都没查。我是怎么表现的？你排在我上面。你去查查看，你表现得——你还不错。
You're doing pretty good. You're a third right now tied for three I was nervous because I picked a lot of upsets as well. I had Harvard I also selected Norfolk State defeating Maryland. Yeah, and Yeah, let me know even Cheyenne Sellers before I pressed record on the interview, she was like, Autumn, your bracket is busted. I was like, heard you. I will be a part of the villain story. It's cool. It's fine.
你表现得挺好。你现在并列第三。我很紧张，因为我也选了很多冷门。我选了哈佛，我还选了诺福克州大击败马里兰州大。对，而且，甚至在采访录音开始前，夏安·塞勒斯就对我说：“奥特姆，你的预测表彻底毁了。”我就想：听到了。我将成为反派故事的一部分。这很酷。没关系。
And they almost defeated South Carolina. That was a great game, but hats off to them. Brenda Frese, she knows what to do on March every single time. Like she's one of the greatest for a reason. Oh, I didn't even think about this idea of you making your bracket, telling us all your bracket and then having to go and sit across from the person that you said was going to get upset. It's fine, though.
而且他们差点就击败了南卡罗来纳州大。那是一场精彩的比赛，但向他们致敬。布伦达·弗里斯，她每次都知道三月份该怎么做。难怪她是史上最伟大的教练之一。哦，我甚至都没想到过这种想法：你做出了预测表，把预测告诉了所有人，然后不得不去和那个被你预测会爆冷淘汰的人面对面坐着。不过没关系。
Has to be, you know, probably the hardest part of the job. You literally put out your fix and you're vulnerable for these reasons. And it just makes a great story at the end of it. You know, I live for it. It's fine. I'll take it. I love that for you. I love it. I love it. OK, so let's talk big picture because we're going to go matchup by matchup.
这一定（你知道的）是这工作中最难的部分。你公开了你的预测，为此你要承担风险。但这最终会成就一个伟大的故事。你知道的，我就是为此而活的。没关系。我接受。我太喜欢你这样了。我太喜欢了。好吧，让我们从宏观角度来聊聊，因为我们接下来要逐场分析对阵。
But just overall, we kind of talked about these four teams heading into the final four. UCLA, UConn, South Carolina and Texas. If this was November and it was preseason, beginning of the season, you are already starting your bracketology, were these four teams in the mix that you thought would be here at this moment? 100%. I mean, these final four teams, it's not shocking that they're here because in the preseason rankings, we saw South Carolina sitting at number one,
但总体而言，我们聊了聊进入四强的这四支球队：UCLA、康涅狄格、南卡罗来纳和德克萨斯。如果现在是11月，是季前赛，是赛季初，你刚开始做你的晋级表预测，你觉得这四支球队会在你认为此时会出现在这里的名单中吗？百分之百。我是说，这四支四强球队，他们出现在这里并不令人震惊，因为在季前赛排名中，我们看到南卡罗来纳排名第一，
UConn at two, USC was at three, four Texas and five UCLA. So my final four predictions, if you would have asked me my first bracketology overall, it would have been South Carolina, USC, UConn, Notre Dame in the final four. But what's still shocking to me is that we still don't have a clear cut champion. And that's just due to all the parity that we've seen, but we've definitely got the best four in the country, duking it out Titans versus Titans. So we could have saw multiple combinations, honestly, like LSU had a great run. Notre Dame, as I mentioned, was my final four team.
康涅狄格第二，南加州大学第三，德克萨斯第四，UCLA第五。所以我的四强预测，如果你问我最初的总体晋级表预测，四强会是南卡罗来纳、南加州大学、康涅狄格、圣母大学。但对我来说仍然震撼的是，我们至今还没有一个毫无争议的绝对冠军。这主要是因为我们看到了太多的势均力敌，但我们绝对拥有全国最强的四支队伍，堪称巨头与巨头的较量。所以老实说，我们本可以看到多种组合，比如LSU经历了一次伟大的征程。正如我所提到的，圣母大学是我的四强球队。
They were right there. And then USC, unfortunately without Juju Watkins, that's easily a final four team, possibly a Four team. They were right there. And then USC, unfortunately, without Juju Watkins, that's easily a Final Four team, possibly a championship team. But these are definitely our Final Four that we got, and kudos to them because they deserve it. They sure do. And yeah, don't make me pick a champion. Maybe by the end of this episode, we will have to pick one. But my gosh, I love that we don't know.
他们当时就在那里。然后是南加州大学，不幸的是失去了朱朱·沃特金斯，那绝对是一支四强球队，甚至可能是一支冠军球队。但这些绝对是我们最终的四强，向他们致敬，因为他们实至名归。他们绝对实至名归。没错，别让我选出一个冠军。也许到这期节目结束时，我们不得不选出一个。但天哪，我喜欢这种充满未知的感觉。
I love that going into Tampa, we're flying in and we're like, ooh, I can't wait to see who plays big because it's really gonna come down to those little things. I think they're all great teams. They're all teams that could win it all, which makes it super fun. We'll talk matchup by matchup, but just storylines. What are some of your favorite storylines
我喜欢当我们飞往坦帕时，我们会想：“噢，我迫不及待地想看看谁能在关键时刻有大心脏表现了，因为这真的要取决于那些微小的细节。”我觉得他们都是伟大的球队。他们都是有实力赢得一切的球队，这让比赛变得超级有趣。我们会逐场对阵进行分析，但就故事线而言。你最喜欢哪些故事线？
from these teams heading into the final? There's so many. Like where do I start? South Carolina, obviously they're looking to run it back and defend their title. That's huge right now. Because of the parody, like I said, there's not a clear cut champion.
关于这些晋级决赛的球队。实在太多了。我从哪里开始说呢？南卡罗来纳，显然他们渴望卫冕并捍卫自己的冠军头衔。这现在意义重大。正如我所说，由于实力平均，并没有一个毫无争议的冠军。
It would be the first time that a team went back to back since UConn did it four straight with the last one being 2016. Speaking of UConn, Page Becker's last ride, obviously they want to restore that success, that legacy that Huskies are known to have. You expect them to win a national championship, but there's been a drought for quite some time,
这将是自康涅狄格大学连续四次夺冠（最后一次是2016年）以来，首次有球队实现连冠。说到康涅狄格，佩奇·贝克斯的最后一舞，显然他们想要重塑哈士奇队历来闻名的辉煌与传奇。你期望他们赢得全国冠军，但这里已经有一段时间闹荒了，
but with Page Becker's leading her team to a final four, again, you want to be in the building for this one, for Page last possible, you know, she has possibly two ahead of her. You want to be there for those games. I'm sure and tune in if you aren't here in Tampa, UCLA first final four. And, you know, this is in the Corey Close era. I think they have the potential of getting it done.
但随着佩奇·贝克斯再次率领她的球队打入四强，你一定会想亲临现场见证佩奇可能的最后一次——你知道的，她可能还有两场比赛。你一定会想去现场观看那些比赛。如果你不在坦帕，我确信你会收看直播。UCLA首次杀入四强。而且，这是在科里·克洛斯时代的首次。我觉得他们有潜力做到这一点。
They have the balance outside of Lauren Betts. So they can definitely make a run for their first ever and bring a championship back to LA, which that's been quite some time too since the eighties. And then for Texas, we have Vic Schaefer who has done it again. I mean, doing what he does best, leading multiple programs to a final four. And this will be Texas first final four since 2003. So a lot of storylines we'll find out May Smith player of the year, coach of the year DPOY on Wednesday. And I want to talk feel good stories too, because I think so many players have great stories as well.
除了劳伦·贝茨，他们阵容均衡。所以他们绝对可以向队史首冠发起冲击，并将冠军带回洛杉矶，这也是自上世纪80年代以来阔别已久的荣耀。至于德克萨斯，我们迎来了再次做到的维克·谢弗。我是说，做他最擅长的事，带领多支不同项目打入四强。这将是德州自2003年以来首次打入四强。所以有太多精彩的故事线了，我们将在周三看到年度最佳球员、年度最佳教练和年度最佳防守球员的揭晓。我还想聊聊那些让人感觉温暖的故事，因为我觉得很多球员也有很棒的故事。
Like Rory Harmon, she, for ACL 10 months later, here she is in the final four. Gabrielle Haka, she grew up wanting to go to UCLA and here she is helping her team to that. And you got the hometown kids and Mylaysia Fulwyle and Joyce Edwards putting on for their city. So it's storylines galore. You want to tune in and just see people win, you know? Absolutely. I mean, we're totally biased because we are in the storytelling business, but it also just makes for a great TV product. It makes for a great sitcom, a great dramedy. Like, I feel like that's what all of this is heading into the Final Four,
比如罗里·哈蒙，她遭遇十字韧带撕裂10个月后，就站在了四强赛的赛场上。加布里埃尔·哈克斯，她从小就梦想去UCLA，而现在她正在帮助球队实现这一目标。还有那些本土球员马来西亚·富怀莱和乔伊斯·爱德华兹为自己的城市争光。所以这里到处都是故事线。你只想收看比赛，看着人们赢得胜利，你知道的？绝对的。我是说，我们完全带有偏见，因为我们从事的是讲故事的行业，但这确实也造就了极佳的电视产品。这就像一部伟大的情景喜剧，一部伟大的悲喜剧。就像，我觉得这就是四强赛所有的走向，
besides the basketball being really, really good, the stories. And it makes any team really easy to root for as well, because I think there's not this... When I look at these teams, I don't see a villain origin story or necessarily an underdog mentality. Like, these are teams that have the best players, have worked hard, and have the feel-good stories mixed in with the program history as well to carry it on.
除了篮球本身非常非常精彩之外，还有这些故事。这也让人们很容易支持任何一支球队，因为我觉得这里没有……当我看着这些球队时，我没有看到反派的起源故事，也没有看到那种绝对的弱者心态。相反，这些球队拥有最优秀的球员，付出了艰辛的努力，并将温馨的故事与球队历史交织在一起，传承下去。
All of these are big time programs with big time names when you think about it. But it's still been so long between UConn, UCLA and Texas. And then South Carolina is like, hey, don't forget about us. We the new kids on the block in this dynasty type of thing. But we want to be here and we also have some things to talk about.
仔细想想，所有这些都是拥有顶级球星的顶级项目。但在康涅狄格、UCLA和德克萨斯之间，已经隔了太久没有夺冠了。然后南卡罗来纳就像是在说：“嘿，别忘了我们。在这类王朝式的格局中，我们是新面孔。”但我们想要来到这里，我们也有一些话要说。
So when we think back, when we think back to the 2024, 25 season, what do you think will be that defining factor that would have defined this college basketball season? Ooh, that's a really great question. Right? No, that's deep. That's deep. That's deep. Honestly, you know, we think about the viewership in that 2024 WNBA draft class with Caitlin Clark, Angel Reese, Rekia Jackson, Cameron Brink, Camila Cardoso, Kate Martin. I can go on and on and on. So Kate Martin, I can go on and on and on. And it didn't stop.
所以当我们回想，当我们回想2024-25赛季时，你觉得会是什么因素来定义这个大学篮球赛季？噢，这真是个好问题。对吧？不，这很深刻。这很深刻。这很深刻。说实话，你知道的，我们想到2024年WNBA选秀大会的收视率和那一届新秀，有凯特琳·克拉克、安吉尔·里斯、雷基亚·杰克逊、卡梅伦·布林克、卡米拉·卡多索、凯特·马丁。我可以一直数下去，数个不停。所以凯特·马丁，我可以一直数下去。而且这并没有停止。
So if I would put into a couple of words or maybe define it in one word, it's like continuation, like a season of continuation and no sign still of slowing down because there is more. We're still talking about Paige Becker's, Olivia Miles, Hannah Hidalgo, Madison Booker, Juju Watkins. Like the talent is endless and women's basketball is here. It is here to stay. And it's exciting. Like people are so excited. I have, you know, you know, my friends texting me, calling me, telling me about the games. I'm like, okay, y'all are locked in.
所以如果我要用几个词来概括，或者用一个词来定义它，那就是“延续”，就像是一个延续的赛季，而且丝毫没有放慢脚步的迹象，因为还有更多精彩。我们仍在讨论佩奇·贝克斯、奥利维亚·迈尔斯、汉娜·伊达尔戈、麦迪逊·布克、朱朱·沃特金斯。天赋层出不穷，女子篮球已经崛起了。它已经在这里扎根了。而且令人兴奋。就像人们都超级兴奋。我有（你知道的）我的朋友们给我发短信、打电话，跟我聊这些比赛。我就想：好吧，你们都太投入了。
And these are casual fans. You don't have to be locked in. You don't have to be a diehard. It's people who are truly invested in what's going on. And it's so exciting. It's so refreshing. And they deserve that. Like we talked all season long about Unrivaled. We talked about the W. We talked about these professional athletes who are performing at the highest level. And thank God people are finally waking up, you know? So, it's been really cool. About time, Autumn, you can say it.
而这些都是普通球迷。你不需要多么硬核。你不需要成为死忠粉。这是那些真正投入到正在发生的事情中的人们。这太令人兴奋了。这太焕然一新了。她们配得上这一切。就像我们整个赛季都在聊“无与伦比”联赛一样。我们聊了WNBA。我们聊了这些在最高水平上表现的职业运动员。感谢上帝，人们终于醒悟过来了，你知道的？所以，这真的很酷。是时候了，奥特姆，你可以说出来。
About time. But also, for the newness, I love... I was gonna say the exact same thing. I love everything that you said. And especially because you can follow this path of this new fan. You can... Maybe Caitlin Clark was that name that brought you in. And you came in during the end of her college season last year, and then you watched her Final Four.
是时候了。但同时，对于这种新鲜感，我喜欢……我正要说同样的话。我喜欢你所说的一切。特别是你可以顺着这位新球迷的轨迹走下去。你可能……也许凯特琳·克拉克就是那个带你入坑的名字。你在去年她大学赛季结束时入坑，然后你看了她的四强赛。
But then you got to watch South Carolina, you got to watch LSU, you got to watch NC State. So you were introduced to all of those programs and you're like, oh dang, okay, who are these? They ballin' out. Then you watch the championship game and you're hooked. And you're like, oh my gosh, I can't wait. Wait, I don't have to wait, I just wait a couple weeks
但随后你看了南卡罗来纳，看了LSU，看了北卡罗来纳州大。所以你接触到了所有这些项目，你会想：“噢，天哪，好吧，这些都是谁？她们太强了。”然后你看了总冠军赛，你就彻底入迷了。你会想：“噢，天哪，我等不及了。等等，我不用等，我只要等几个星期
and then the WNBA season starts. Like you can see this through line of the fandom and how maybe it started last year, but you are definitely coming back. And maybe you bought tickets to Tampa because you're so excited from last season. So that has been my favorite part. And I definitely think that people maybe were,
然后WNBA赛季就开始了。”就像你能看到粉丝群体的这条主线，也许它始于去年，但你绝对还会再回来。也许你买去坦帕的票是因为你对上个赛季感到无比兴奋？所以这一直是我最喜欢的部分。我绝对认为人们可能曾经，
maybe the doubters were expecting a huge drop-off, but there was not a drop-off. And that is so exciting to me that it's continuing to build, that we have been seeing all the commercials, all the opportunities, all the investment. Like, I loved... We were watching the ESPN halftime report. Some rounds, it was sponsored by Degree.
也许那些怀疑论者曾预计会有巨大的下滑，但并没有下滑。这让我感到非常兴奋，它在继续建立，我们看到了所有的商业广告、所有的机会、所有的投资。我喜欢……我们当时在看ESPN的中场休息报道。某些场次是由Degree赞助的。
And then it turns into a new sponsor. It's sponsored by Shane Moisture. Me and my husband were like, okay, we're doing, you know, ads by rounds now. Like before there was no sponsors for the women's events and the women's March Madness. So there is this overwhelming sense of investment and it has not slowed down. If anything, it's picking up more steam. And when we get to the Final Four and the biggest stage, again, I'll say it, the basketball is super good and exciting and the stars are starring. And then we have the eyeballs to go with it.
然后换成了新的赞助商。它是由Shea Moisture赞助的。我和我丈夫当时就想：“好吧，我们现在按轮次做广告了。”以前女篮赛事和女篮疯狂三月是没有赞助商的。所以有一种压倒性的投资感，而且它并没有放慢脚步。如果有的话，它的势头正在变得越来越猛。当我们进入四强赛和最大的舞台时，我还是要说，篮球真的非常精彩且令人兴奋，球星们都在闪耀。而且我们有了相应的关注度。
So that's just what gets me super excited heading into this final four. But enough of the big picture, we're gonna get down to the teams. Let's pay some bills real quick, but we'll be right back. Some people play it safe, but that's never been my style. I'm Soraya, and this is Roll Breakers, the podcast where we celebrate the rebels, the misfits and the ones who make their own way.
所以这正是让我对即将到来的四强赛感到超级兴奋的原因。好了，宏观大局就聊到这儿，我们要回到各支球队身上。让我们快速处理一下商业广告，我们马上回来。有些人喜欢走稳妥路线，但这从来不是我的风格。我是索拉娅，这里是《破局者》，这是一个致敬叛逆者、格格不入者以及那些走自己路的播客节目。
Every week I sit down with athletes, entertainers and industry disruptors who don't just push the boundaries now. They shatter them. We talk about the wildest risks they've taken, the lessons they've learned and the moments that made them who they are. No fillers, no BS, just real talk with people who refuse to follow the script. And we don't just talk about breaking the rules now,
每周我都与那些不仅打破界限，而且将其粉碎的运动员、艺人和行业颠覆者坐在一起。我们聊聊他们冒过的最大风险、学到的教训，以及那些塑造了他们自我的时刻。没有注水，没有废话，只有与那些拒绝按剧本生活的人进行的真实对话。我们不仅仅是谈论打破常规，
we prove it. Think dog shot collars, bug trivia, blindfold tattoos, and text roulette. The stakes are high and the chaos is real. So if you've ever been told to stay in your lane, this show is for you. Follow and listen to Rule Breakers with Soraya, an Odyssey podcast available now for free on the Odyssey app and wherever you get your podcasts.
我们要证明它。想想狗狗电击项圈、虫子冷知识、蒙眼纹身和短信轮盘赌。赌注很高，混乱是真实的。所以，如果你曾被告知要安分守己，这个节目就是为你准备的。关注并收听由索拉娅主持的《破局者》，这是一档奥德赛播客，现已在奥德赛应用程序及各大播客平台免费上线。
Welcome back to the Women's Hook Show. And before we get to our Final Four preview, let's, let's, how did we get here? For each of these teams, how did they earn this spot? Let's give a little recap of how they got here. And let's start with UCLA against LSU. That was their Elite Eight matchup. This was a rematch from last season. UCLA lost to LSU and it was a winnable game last year.
欢迎回到《女子篮球秀》。在我们进行四强赛前瞻之前，让我们先回顾一下：我们是怎么走到这一步的？对于这些球队中的每一支，她们是如何赢得这个席位的？让我们对她们如何走到这里做一个小小的总结。让我们从UCLA对阵LSU开始。那是她们的精英八强对决。这是上赛季的复刻战。UCLA输给了LSU，而去年那本是一场完全可以取胜的比赛。
So I know they had been thinking about this all year long. There was also some drama around this last year. Maybe you remember about the LA Times article that came out and really pitted the two teams against each other, essentially saying that one team was better than the other because of, I don't know, overall vibe, I guess you could say, Autumn. It was a poorly written opinion article
所以我知道她们一整年都在想着这件事。去年这场比赛周围还有一些戏剧性事件。也许你还记得关于《洛杉矶时报》发表的那篇文章，它真正将两支球队对立起来，基本上是说其中一支球队比另一支球队更好，因为，我不知道，整体氛围，我想你可以这么说，奥特姆。那是一篇写得很差的专栏文章，
that the writer has since apologized for. But that's all to say, there's some extra animosity heading into this game. And Flage Johnson wanted all the smoke and she wanted it. But UCLA was able to win it 72 to 65 over an LSU team that was coming back. But what did you kind of see in this game to get UCLA over the hump of LSU? Yeah, well, just looking at UCLA, like in the region they played in, you looked at it
作者后来已经为此道歉了。但总而言之，在这场比赛到来之前，多了一层额外的火药味。弗莱吉·约翰逊渴望所有的激烈对抗，她就是想要这个。但UCLA最终以72比65击败了卷土重来的LSU。但在这场比赛中，你觉得是什么让UCLA跨越了LSU这座大山？对，好吧，看看UCLA，就像她们所处的赛区，你看着它
and said, okay, no one can match up the foreign bets at six, seven in the skill that she possesses. But LSU truly challenged them. I mean, Flage Johnson coming out with 28 points and Nisa Morrow having that main challenge down low. It didn't matter. Like she pulled the ball out, was knocking threes down, was knocking 10 footers, no matter what, getting in transition, banging down low. Nisa Morrow is going to go down as one of the greatest we have seen in this game. And she said it herself, like, no one has done what I've done in my college career. Miss Double Double with 104 Double Doubles overall, that's insane to say.
会说：“好吧，没有人能在身高6尺7寸以及她所拥有的技术上与劳伦·贝茨匹配。”但LSU确实对她们构成了挑战。我是说，弗莱吉·约翰逊砍下28分，尼萨·莫罗在内线构成了主要挑战。这根本没用。她把球拉到外线，投进三分，投进10英尺跳投，无论如何，在转换进攻中，在内线强打。尼萨·莫罗必将作为我们在本场比赛中见证的最伟大的球员之一载入史册。她自己也说过，没有人做到过我在大学生涯中所做的事情。拿到104次两双的两双机器，总共104次两双，说出来太疯狂了。
Like, what? That's crazy. 104 is crazy, and she's consistently leading the nations in Double Double. So I had no questions or concerns going ahead, going up against Lauren Betts or just anyone in the paint, how she altered shots at 6-7. It didn't bluster or bother Anissa whatsoever. But the thing about it, when we look at UCLA, we always talk about Lauren Betts. But here's the Bruins saying, hello, there's more. And I think this tournament alone is showcasing the balance
就像，什么？太疯狂了。104次太疯狂了，她一直领跑全国的两双榜。所以在面对劳伦·贝茨或禁区里的任何人时，我对她的投篮出手以及她在6尺7寸的身高下如何干扰投篮没有任何疑问或担忧。这丝毫没有让尼萨感到慌乱或困扰。但关键在于，当我们看UCLA时，我们总是谈论劳伦·贝茨。但布鲁因人却在说：“嗨，还有更多呢。”我觉得仅凭这次锦标赛就展现了UCLA的均衡性
that UCLA has. This has been all season long. This isn't just a coming out party for Gabriella Hocka. She is the unsung hero of this team. And if you have been watching them closely, she's had games like this. She's had timely moments like this. 18 points to lead her team team four for five from deep.
整个赛季一直都是这样。这不仅仅是加布里埃尔·哈克斯的成名秀。她是这支球队的无名英雄。如果你一直密切关注她们，她其实打过很多这样的比赛。她有过许多这样关键时刻的表现。18分领全队，三分球5投4中。
Those were game changing threes. And she also did it on both ends. She had to guard Lajay Johnson, Michaela Williams, like two of the best guards we have seen in this game as well. That's not an easy feat whatsoever. And she does it on both ends. She still has the energy to knock down those big shots. But you also had Tania Gartner coming off the bench. 15 points. You're talking about pieces you got in the transfer
这些都是改变比赛走向的三分球。而且她攻防两端都有贡献。她必须防守弗莱吉·约翰逊、米凯拉·威廉姆斯，也就是我们在比赛中见过的最优秀的两个后卫。这绝非易事。而且她攻防兼备。她依然有体能命中那些关键进球。但你还有替补出场的塔尼亚·加德纳。15分。你在谈论通过转会引援得到的球员
portal that are now coming into play. And she's been able to break out as well throughout the course of the season, but in a timely manner, 15 points, including five threes. That was difference-maker. I think the balance has been that all season long, and it's definitely gonna help as they try to pursue a championship. Absolutely. 41% from the three-point line for UCLA, and when they're knocking those down and having Lauren Betts inside, you...
现在终于发挥作用了。整个赛季中她也一直在爆发，但在关键时刻，15分，包括5个三分球。这成了胜负手。我觉得整个赛季以来这种均衡性一直都在，当她们向冠军发起冲击时，这绝对会大有帮助。绝对的。UCLA的三分命中率达到了41%，当她们能投进这些三分，内线又有劳伦·贝茨坐镇时，你……
Good luck. What do you choose? I don't know. Good luck. Kim Mulkey, the head coach of LSU, said that that game was won or lost in the second quarter. And to put it in perspective, Lauren Betts gets two fouls early, which by the way, she has never done before. This was her first DMP in a quarter of her career.
祝你好运。你选哪个？我不知道。祝你好运。LSU的主教练金·穆基表示，那场比赛的胜负是在第二节决定的。为了让大家有个直观概念，劳伦·贝茨很早便身背两次犯规，顺便说一句，她以前从未这样过。这是她职业生涯中首次在单节遭遇犯规麻烦。
She did not play the entire second quarter. And, you know, for this other show that I'm doing, Unlocked on Women's Basketball, we talked about kind of the difference between her and Cameron Brink as a post player and how Cameron Brink at Stanford, that was her detriment. She would get in foul trouble,
她整个第二节都没上场。而且，对于我主持的另一个节目《锁定女篮》，我们讨论了她和卡梅伦·布林克作为内线球员的区别，以及卡梅伦·布林克在斯坦福大学时，这曾是她的软肋。她会陷入犯规麻烦，
and Stanford had to like really know how to play without her because it happened so often. Lauren Betts does not foul. She is so smart and has body control and as a shot blocker at 6'7", that is really hard to do. But she sits out the entire second quarter and everyone's like, uh oh, this is where LSU is going to turn up. No, that's where Tamiya Gardner makes three threes. That's where Gabrielle Jaquez has five points.
斯坦福不得不真正学会如何在没有她的情况下打球，因为这种情况经常发生。劳伦·贝茨不怎么犯规。她非常聪明，身体控制能力极强，作为身高6尺7寸的盖帽手，这真的很难做到。但她第二节整节坐在场下，所有人都想：“噢哦，这就是LSU要起势的时候了。”不，这正是塔尼亚·加德纳命中三个三分球的时候。这正是加布里埃尔·哈克斯得到5分的时候。
Kiki has two points. And it's like, oh, they have other people that can show up. And LSU did not take advantage of those minutes when bets were not on the floor. And that's what the coach said. It didn't even matter what happened in the third quarter. Didn't matter what happened in the fourth quarter. They did not take advantage and go on a run
基基得了2分。这就好比，噢，她们还有其他人能挺身而出。而LSU并没有利用好贝茨不在场上的那些时间。这就是教练所说的。第三节发生什么甚至都不重要了。第四节发生什么也不重要。她们没有抓住机会打出一波流
and force Cory Close to put Lauren Betts back in. And that was a huge difference maker. Would you agree? I would agree. I mean, 22 and six in that second quarter, would you have pictured that without Lauren Betts Jordan? Like to me, that's, to me, that's, that says a lot about the Bruins and they are not peaking
并迫使科里·克洛斯把劳伦·贝茨换回场上。这成了巨大的胜负分水岭。你同意吗？我同意。我是说，在没有劳伦·贝茨的情况下第二节打出22比6，你能想象得到吗，乔丹？对我和我而言，这说明了关于布鲁因人太多的事情，她们可能不是
at the right time, but they're just playing their best basketball at the right time. And their teammates are stepping up in the moments that are needed the most. And even before that, Lauren Betts had a 30 and 10 game. Like she's coming in and she's not being denied at this moment. We saw that in the big 10 championship game too, willing her team to a win that want to and you have all the pieces.
在刚刚好的时间达到巅峰，但她们在刚刚好的时间打出了自己最好的篮球。她们的队友在最需要的时刻挺身而出。甚至在此之前，劳伦·贝茨刚砍下30分10篮板。她此时此刻的状态就是势不可挡。我们在十大联盟冠军赛中也看到了这一点，她凭借一己之力带领球队赢得胜利，而且你们拥有所有的拼图。
I think this year compared to last year, they have the experience, they have the pieces, they have the depth, they have the balance. Now it's like that extra grit to them. That extra confidence, that swag, that just want to overall. That I will not be denied. And I think that is what separates you from other teams. Yeah, for sure.
我觉得今年与去年相比，她们有经验，有拼图，有阵容深度，有均衡性。现在她们身上多了一种额外的韧性。那种额外的自信，那种霸气，那种对胜利的渴望。那种“我绝不会被击败”的心态。我觉得这正是你与其他球队区分开来的地方。是的，确实如此。
Well, LSU, they're gonna try to figure it out. The one stat that really stuck out to me was coming into this Elite Eight game against UCLA. LSU was 16 and 0 when Flage scored over 20 points and she dropped 28. She played amazing. She's only a sophomore. She is eligible to go into the WNBA draft,
好了，LSU，她们会想办法弄明白的。真正让我印象深刻的一个数据是，在进入这场对阵UCLA的精英八强赛之前，当弗莱吉得分超过20分时，LSU的战绩是16胜0负，而她这场砍下了28分。她打得太棒了。她才大二。她有资格参加WNBA选秀，
but my guess is that she's going to come back because I think there's other parts of her game that she can continue to grow. I also, I think a part of these guesses are I think she's coming back to LSU, but we'll see. We'll see. I don't know. Who knows? But Flage, she balled out. We know what she's going to do with LSU. Let's move on to the next number one team. Who's in the Final Four, South Carolina versus Duke in that Elite A game. Oh my goodness. This was such a good game. It was a very low scoring affair.
但我的猜测是她会选择留校，因为我认为她比赛中还有其他方面可以继续成长。而且，我也觉得这些猜测中的一部分是她会回到LSU，但我们走着瞧。我们走着瞧。谁知道呢？但弗莱吉，她打得很棒。我们知道她在LSU的表现。让我们转向下一支头号种子球队。谁进入了四强？南卡罗来纳对阵杜克，在精英八强赛中。噢天哪。这真是一场精彩的比赛。这是一场得分很低的较量。
54 to 50. South Carolina barely hangs on to win that game, which we talked about the last game being in the second quarter. This game was one or lost in like the last two minutes, I would say. Duke had all the momentum, kind of fell apart with a few decision-makings towards the end there. And to me, Autumn, this was experience. This was experience over, don't panic, don't panic. Oh, we panicked. That's how I felt Duke kind of looked 100% in there. But South Carolina did not play their best against Maryland, barely won that one.
54比50。南卡罗来纳艰难赢下比赛，我们刚才聊了上一场比赛是在第二节决定的。这场比赛的胜负大概是在最后两分钟决定的，我想这么说。杜克一度拥有所有势头，只是在最后阶段由于几次决策失误而有些崩盘。对我来说，奥特姆，这就是经验。这就是经验战胜了“别慌，别慌”。噢，我们慌了。我觉得杜克当时看起来就是这样。但南卡罗来纳对阵马里兰时打得并不好，那场赢得很惊险。
Then they come in and they barely went against Duke. I don't think we expected this type of performance this late. Especially when we see other teams who are, you know, blown out by 20 or more points. That's what South Carolina used to do. But now these, these are a little close and I was, I was a little nervous. Were you a little nervous? I was definitely nervous.
然后她们遇到杜克，又险胜。我们没想到会在这么晚的阶段看到这种表现。特别是当我们看到其他球队（你知道的）以20分或更多的优势大胜时。那才是南卡罗来纳过去常做的事。但现在这些，这些比赛都太胶着了，我当时，我当时有点紧张。你当时有点紧张吗？我绝对很紧张。
I was screaming at the TV and honestly, Jordan, I think we're all spoiled at this point because Yeah, we are. We are used to seeing South Carolina dominate. And I want to read you something because I thought this was very interesting. During last year's run to the final four, South Carolina trailed for a total of one minute and 10 seconds.
我当时对着电视尖叫，说实话，乔丹，我觉得我们现在都被惯坏了，因为，是的，我们确实被惯坏了。我们习惯了看到南卡罗来纳统治比赛。我想读一段话给你听，因为我觉得这非常有趣。在去年通往四强的征程中，南卡罗来纳总共落后的时间只有1分10秒。
One minute and 10 seconds. One minute and 10 seconds. This year, the Gamecocks were behind for a total of 36 minutes and 27 seconds, which was still really good. It's still a low number, but one minute. South Carolina was blowing through teams, flying colors throughout this whole championship pursuit. And now we're so used to that, so accustomed to it. It's like, whoa, hold on now. Like these are some tight games and we haven't had to hold our breath like this for a minute for South Carolina.
1分10秒。1分10秒。今年，南卡罗来纳落后的总时间是36分27秒，其实这依然很优秀。这仍然是个很低的数字，但跟1分钟相比……南卡罗来纳过去在整个争冠过程中都是顺风顺水、大比分击溃对手的。现在我们对那种表现习以为常、理所当然了。就会觉得：“哇，等等。这些比赛怎么这么胶着，我们已经好久没为南卡罗来纳这么提心吊胆了。”
So when I looked at that game, Duke had plenty of opportunity to make it happen and shake the world. But like you said, that experience really played through. Like they've been here. We talked about this last episode. They've been here before. A lot of these players, I think it's like eight players overall on this current roster, were here last year.
所以当我看到那场比赛时，杜克有充足的机会去创造奇迹并震撼世界。但正如你所说，经验确实起到了作用。她们曾经历过。我们在上一期节目中谈过这个。她们以前来过这里。这支现有阵容中的许多球员，我想总共大约有八名球员去年就在这里了。
And then they bring on some new pieces. They have that bench. For me, it has been the bench in these close stretches. In the first round, we saw a record breaking 66 points. Indiana, it was 19 points. That was a really close nail biter. Maryland was 40 points, but in that Duke game, guess how many bench points?
然后她们引进了新拼图。她们拥有板凳深度。对我来说，在这些胶着的阶段，是板凳席站了出来。在第一轮，我们看到了破纪录的66分。对阵印第安纳，那是19分。那是一场非常惊险的恶战。对阵马里兰是40分，但在对阵杜克的比赛中，你猜替补席得了多少分？
Nine. This is a team that leads the nation in bench points. It's about 40 on the regular season, 33 coming off the bench during this NCAA tournament run, around that average, but nine points coming off the bench versus Duke. Whoa. That is such a good stat.
9分。这是一支在常规赛替补得分领跑全国的球队。常规赛场均大约40分，在这次NCAA锦标赛征程中替补场均贡献33分，差不多是这个平均水平，但在对阵杜克的比赛中替补席只得了9分。哇。这真是一个太棒的数据了。
Malaysia Pauwai is that main person that is coming off the bench. Joyce Edwards, Tessa Johnson, all single digits. Yeah. Wow. And they still manage to get the win. And so I think it says a lot about that. I will say, and this may come off a little harsh, but I'm okay. I could take it. We talk a lot about how you don't want to bet against Dawn Staley. And you can't bet against Dawn Staley. And you can't bet against Dawn Staley. But at the end of the day, Dawn Staley can't go out on the floor
马来西亚·富怀莱是替补席上的主要火力。乔伊斯·爱德华兹、苔丝·约翰逊，全部都是个位数。是的。哇。而她们依然设法赢得了比赛。所以我觉得这充分说明了这一点。我要说的是，这听起来可能有点严厉，但我没关系。我能承受。我们经常讨论你不想跟道恩·斯塔利作对。你确实不能跟道恩·斯塔利作对。你确实不能跟道恩·斯塔利作对。但归根结底，道恩·斯塔利不能自己上场去为她的球队打球。她不能去打控球后卫，她不能穿上球衣去掌控全局。我对一场精英八强赛中的比赛态度产生了质疑。杜克抢到了每一个五五开的球、每一个地滚球、每一个进攻篮板，飞扑救球。托比·富尼耶表现惊艳，砍下18分。阿什琳·杰克逊得到13分。这就好比，你知道的，我们谈到了中场休息时的演讲，
and play for her team. She can't be the point guard, she can't put on a jersey and run the show. And I question effort in an Elite Eight game. Duke was getting every 50-50 ball, every loose ball, every offensive rebound, flying in. Toby Fournier played amazing, 18 points. Ashlyn Jackson had 13 points. It was, you know, we talk about the halftime speeches,
并为她的球队效力。她不能担任控球后卫，不能穿上球衣去掌控全场。而且我对一场精英八强赛中的拼劲提出了质疑。杜克大学抢到了每一个五五开的球、每一个地滚球、每一个进攻篮板，飞扑救球。托比·富尼耶表现惊艳，砍下18分。阿什琳·杰克逊得到13分。这真是，你知道的，我们谈到了中场休息时的演讲，
being goaded. It can't take a half time speech at this point to light that fire again. And this game specifically, I didn't see that third quarter South Carolina team. Like it wasn't this miraculous turnaround that we were kind of all expecting because they have slow starts.
被激怒了。这时候光靠一次中场休息的演讲已经无法重新点燃斗志了。特别是这场比赛，我没有看到那个第三节的南卡罗来纳队。这并不是我们大家所期望的那种奇迹般的逆转，因为他们总是开局慢热。
So I don't know, I want this little break before this next game that they really, really realize that they are a great team, that they can beat teams, but it starts with themselves and it has to start the game that way. I think as we are getting to the final four, they have played really good teams and they barely inched it out. Now they are going to play final four. They have played really good teams and they barely inched it out.
所以，我不知道，我希望在下一场比赛前的这段小长假里，他们能真正地、真正地意识到他们是一支伟大的球队，他们能够击败任何对手，但这要从他们自身做起，而且从比赛一开始就必须这样。我认为在我们迈向四强（Final Four）的过程中，他们对阵过非常强劲的对手，并且都是险胜。现在他们将要进入四强。他们对阵过非常强劲的对手，并且都是险胜。
Now they are going to play a great team in Texas and they are going to play a great team in either UCLA or UConn. And those little mistakes or those second effort plays, it is going to come down to that. So South Carolina, I plead you to be the team that we know that you are. And that starts from within. It can't always come from your head. Great point. That's an amazing point. And to your point, teams are coming in hungry. We've talked about, oh, since 2003, this is the last time, first time in program history. These teams are coming in here and South Carolina has been here for a fifth year straight.
现在他们将在德克萨斯迎战一支伟大的球队，接着他们将在加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）或康涅狄格大学（UConn）中迎战另一支伟大的球队。那些小失误或第二次拼抢的球，最终都将决定胜负。所以南卡罗来纳，我恳求你们成为我们所熟知的那支强队。而这必须发自内心。这不能总靠主教练的训话。说得好。这真是个精彩的观点。而且正如你所说，对手们都气势汹汹、求胜心切。我们讨论过，哦，自2003年以来，这是球队历史上第一次。这些球队气势汹汹地杀入这里，而南卡罗来纳已经连续五年闯入这里了。
Teams are coming in hungry, starving for this moment. And when you look at Texas, they've already battled them three times. We're going to get this a fourth time. They've cracked the code once. It is hard playing a team multiple times because they have you figured it out. And then on the other side, either UCLA and Yukon, they both have wins over South Carolina. Everyone in the Spinal Four has a win over South Carolina. And now you're facing them possibly again, if you get past Texas and then have to
对手们来势汹汹，对这个时刻渴望至极。当你看看德克萨斯队时，他们已经和她们交手三次了。我们马上要迎来第四次交手。她们已经破解过一次密码了。与一支球队多次交手是很困难的，因为他们已经摸清了你的套路。而在另一边，无论是UCLA还是康涅狄格，他们都有战胜南卡罗来纳的胜绩。四强中的每个人都对南卡罗来纳有过胜绩。现在你可能又要面对她们了，如果你能击败德克萨斯，然后必须
face either or you have that scouting report, you know what needs to be done. It could get sticky. That is a great point. I didn't even realize that. That's probably their worst nightmare. They only have three losses, right, on the season. Is that correct? It's to all these teams. Yes.
面对其中任何一个，你就会有那份球探报告，你知道该做些事情。事情可能会变得棘手。这真是个绝佳的观点。我甚至都没意识到这一点。这可能是他们最可怕的噩梦。他们整个赛季只有三场失利，对吧？是这样吗？就是输给这些球队。是的。
Yeah. I mean... Talk about a storyline. That makes it interesting. Give me all of it. I need it. Ugh. Let's go. Okay, well, moving on from Duke, had a great season. The Cara era is live and well They have a lot to be proud of again. It really came down to just those final minutes They were almost there to upsetting South Carolina, but they'll clean those up. I do think coming into next season
是的。我是说……谈论一个故事情节。这让比赛变得有趣。把所有这些都给我。我需要它。呃。我们走吧。好吧，抛开杜克大学不谈，他们度过了一个伟大的赛季。卡拉时代正在蓬勃发展，他们再次有很多值得骄傲的事情。这真的归结于最后的几分钟。他们差一点就能爆冷击败南卡罗来纳，但他们会吸取教训的。我确实认为进入下赛季
There's a couple names in the portal that are offensive threats. They need to get an offensive threat who loves to play defense as well. And that player is out there, and I think that is that one piece that Duke is missing to put them over the edge. But to be able to win an Elite Eight game for South Carolina at 54 points is absolutely insane. And that was their lowest point scored all season.
转会市场上会有几个具备进攻威胁的名字。他们需要引进一个同样热爱防守的进攻威胁点。这样的球员是存在的，我认为这就是杜克缺少的、能让他们更上一层楼的关键拼图。但南卡罗来纳能在精英八强赛（Elite Eight）中仅靠54分就赢下一场比赛，这绝对是疯狂的。这也是他们整个赛季得分最低的一场比赛。
So that's what Duke Defense does to you. All right, Texas, TCU, holy crap, the Battle of Texas, that was so much fun. I knew that this was going to be fun. We talk about defense, Texas, all defense, TCU, all offense, led by Haley VanLeth, and then Texas led by Madison Booker and Rory Harmon. But Texas came out on top. They said, it's all about the burnt orange. Hook them. 58 to 47 in their Elite Eight matchup. This is the first time, like you mentioned,
所以这就是杜克防守对你做的事。好了，德克萨斯对决TCU（德克萨斯基督教大学），天哪，德克萨斯之战，太有趣了。我知道这会很有趣。我们谈论防守，德克萨斯，全防守；TCU，全进攻，由海莉·范利斯（Haley Van Lith）率领，然后德克萨斯由麦迪逊·布克（Madison Booker）和罗里·哈蒙（Rory Harmon）率领。但德克萨斯笑到了最后。他们说，一切为了焦橙色。上吧，长角牛！在他们的精英八强对决中以58比47取胜。正如你所提到的，这是第一次
Autumn Texas is going to the Final Four. Since 2003, Maddie Booker balled out 18 points. 14 of them were in the second half. Rory Harmon, to me, was the star because she doesn't typically score as heavy, but she was like, I'm calling my number today and 13 points, 11 of those were in the first half. So what stood out to you from this Texas team saying we are the inferior Texas school?
秋天（Autumn），德克萨斯要进四强了。麦迪·布克狂砍18分。其中14分是在下半场得到的。在我看来，罗里·哈蒙才是明星，因为她通常得分没有那么重，但她当时说，我今天要站出来，砍下13分，其中11分是在上半场得到的。那么，这支德克萨斯队有什么让你印象深刻的地方，让他们能够证明我们才是德克萨斯更强的学校？
Well, you knew coming in, Texas was going to hang its hat on defense. And TCU is a great offensive team and not just great, they're super efficient. When I think of, you know, in terms of scoring inside and out, they got three ball, they can work off ball screen actions. Like they are constantly moving and you have to, you have to be on your P's and Q's when you're facing them. And that's exactly what Texas did. They looked uncomfortable.
嗯，你从一开始就知道，德克萨斯会把防守作为他们的底牌。而TCU是一支伟大的进攻球队，不仅仅是伟大，他们超级高效。当我想到，你知道的，就内外线得分而言，他们有三分球，他们可以利用无球掩护战术。就像他们一直在跑动，当你面对他们时，你必须全神贯注、保持警惕。而这正是德克萨斯所做的。他们看起来很不自在。
They looked sped up. They looked, and times were like in discomfort for a full course of 40 minutes that they really couldn't get anything going. You know, Madison Booker shining as she always does, Rory Harmon as well. These two together are a nightmare. But honestly, I thought the unsung hero too
他们看起来节奏被打乱了。他们看起来，在整整40分钟的比赛里，时时刻刻都处于煎熬之中，以至于他们根本无法打出任何东西。你知道的，麦迪逊·布克像往常一样闪耀，罗里·哈蒙也是如此。这两个人加在一起简直就是一场噩梦。但说实话，我也认为那个无名英雄
was Kyla Ode for two. Like she came in and did what needed to be done inside. She had some impressive game changing moments, some energy plays as well. Just, just Hank, like just really holding down the paint. So I love the effort on all ends, both ends for this Texas team. And, and it took them a minute to get going for TCU and in an elite eight game, like you can't have that, but they were like, they should be proud of what they were able to do and stay close with them. With Sedona Prince, obviously with foul trouble, she ended with like four points. That hurts you because that's a main piece of your big three. But credit to the Longhorns defense. Like that was true Texas fight.
是凯拉·奥德（Kyla Oldaker）。就像她上场后在内线做好了该做的事情。她有一些令人印象深刻的、改变比赛走势的时刻，还有一些充满能量的精彩表现。就是，就是死守，真的是在油漆区筑起防线。所以我喜欢这支德克萨斯队在各个方面的努力，攻防两端都是。而且，TCU花了一会儿才进入状态，在一场精英八强赛中，你不能这样，但他们会觉得，他们应该为自己所做到的事情以及能够紧咬比分感到骄傲。随着索多娜·普林斯（Sedona Prince）显然陷入犯规麻烦，她最终只得了大约4分。这很伤士气，因为这是你三巨头中的核心部分。但必须赞誉长角牛的防守。这真是真正的德克萨斯式的拼搏。
And it was really cool to see how, you know, a lot of people, including myself, was saying like, I'm going to put that out there because it's on the record. Like I would say that too. Like, it's all the record. Come on, let's be real. Like a lot of people. You weren't thinking it. You weren't thinking they were going to make it this far.
看到很多人，包括我自己，都在说——把这个记录下来，因为有案可查。我会这么说的。这有案可查。拜托，说实话。就像很多人一样。你当时可没这么想。你当时可没想过他们能走这么远。
And they said, we're winning this for Autumn Johnson. No, I'll thinking it. You weren't thinking they were going to make it this far. And they said, we're winning this for Autumn Johnson. Only because, no, I'll take it. Because the only reason I said that is because I'm like, hey, you know, I want to see if they can get some threes to go to like, you know, that outside shot a little bit more. They get to the rim constantly. They get in the mid-range, but will that be enough? They said, yeah, because teams still have to score on us. Like, yes. Heard you. Big Shaper, a legend.
而他们说，我们要为奥特姆·约翰逊（Autumn Johnson）赢得这场比赛。不，我会接受的。因为我这么说的唯一原因是因为我想，嘿，你知道的，我想看看他们能不能投进一些三分球，（你知道的）稍微多一点外线投篮。他们不断杀入篮下。他们能打中距离，但这够吗？他们说，是的，因为对手仍然要在我们身上得分。没错。听到没。大人物谢珀，一个传奇。
And truthfully, honestly, if they can hang their hat on defense and make teams like just search for offense like that, they're a problem. They've been a problem and they've constantly shown us that game after game. So funny. I love how you've been doing the threes because they went two for three from the three point line. They don't shoot threes. Meanwhile, they don't shoot threes. They only make three a game as a team, which is just unheard of, especially in this day and age of basketball. Also a stat that jumps out to me from this box score, 21 to 8, and that is turnovers. TCU turned the ball over 21 times. A lot of that was in that first quarter, the first half, where they were getting five second violations, half court, shot clock
老实说，如果他们能把防守作为底牌，让对手像这样艰难地寻找进攻机会，他们就是一个大麻烦。他们一直都是个麻烦，而且他们在每场比赛中都不断向我们展示这一点。太搞笑了。我喜欢你一直在关注三分球，因为他们三分线外2投3中。他们不投三分。与此同时，他们根本不投三分。作为一支球队，他们一场比赛只能投进三个，这简直闻所未闻，尤其是在当今的篮球时代。另外一个让我从这份数据统计中注意到的数据是，21比8，那是失误数。TCU出现了21次失误。其中很大一部分发生在第一节、上半场，当时他们出现了5秒违例、半场、进攻时间
violations, throwing the ball out of bounds. It was, I'm uncomfy with this pressure. Like, please back away. And Texas was like, no, we're not. We're gonna keep coming. That was a fun matchup to watch. And talk about stories. TCU is such an incredible story. For those who don't know,
违例，把球扔出界外。当时的情况是，我对这种压迫感到很不舒服。求求你们退后一点吧。而德克萨斯则说，不，我们不。我们会继续逼抢。那是一场看得很过瘾的对决。说到故事。TCU真的是一个不可思议的故事。对于那些不知道的人来说，
CCU was, they needed tryouts, open tryouts last year. And the year before that, they were one in 17 in conference. Just an incredible story for them to be at this level and Hailey Van Lyft to take another team to the Elite Eight. We wanted that, I did come around to it like, okay, this would be kind of cool if they went to the Final Four because this is an unexpected group to get this far. But Texas was like, no, no, no, no. It's our time to go to the Final Four. So we're going to take that. I did want to go back one game real quick and how TCU even got to this point is that they beat Notre Dame.
CCU（译者注：此处主持人口误将TCU说成CCU）是，他们去年需要通过试训、公开试训来组建队伍。而在那之前的一年，他们在分区赛中1胜17负。对于他们能达到这个水平，以及海莉·范利斯带领另一支球队打进精英八强来说，这绝对是一个不可思议的故事。我们想要这个，我确实慢慢接受了这一点，心想：好吧，如果他们能进四强会挺酷的，因为这是一支意料之外能走这么远的队伍。但德克萨斯说，不，不，不，不。轮到我们进四强了。所以我们要拿下它。我确实想快速回到上一场比赛，TCU是如何走到这一步的，那就是他们击败了圣母大学。
And when I say beat, they beat them. Notre Dame played terrible. I think we all watched that. They did not shoot the ball well around 31% from the field, if I believe. 31% from the field, if I believe. The only other team that held Notre Dame to under 37% prior to that was TCU. So I thought, because I also picked Notre Dame to win that game, I thought it was going to be this, rah rah, they beat us earlier in the season, but we're better now. And then they proved that they were not better, actually, in this moment.
当我说是击败时，他们是真的击败了。圣母大学打得太烂了。我想我们都看了那场比赛。他们投篮很不准，如果我没记错的话，投篮命中率只有31%左右。投篮命中率31%，如果我没记错的话。在此之前，唯一将圣母大学限制在37%以下的另一支球队就是TCU。所以我想，因为我也选了圣母大学赢得那场比赛，我以为这会是一场充满激情的复仇战：他们在赛季初击败了我们，但我们现在更强了。然后他们实际上在这场比赛中证明了他们其实并没有变好。
And TCU just won that game. Hailey Van Lyp went on for 26 points. But we got to say bye-bye to Notre Dame, and we didn't expect to so soon. We all picked it. We did. I mean, it was that back-to-back loss experience in the beginning of the season. We're like, oh, it's the Cayman Islands.
而TCU就那样赢得了比赛。海莉·范利斯砍下了26分。但我们不得不向圣母大学说再见，我们没想到会这么快。我们都预测了比赛结果。确实如此。我的意思是，那是赛季初遭遇背靠背失利的经历。我们当时想，哦，那是在开曼群岛。
Like, it's behind them. And they went on, I think it was like a 19 game winning streak, so I was like, okay, cool. Like, this is a different team that stumbled down the end. They're gonna get it together with this break coming into the NCAA tournament. TCU said, no, this is our year. We're gonna ride it.
就像，这一切都过去了。然后他们开启了一波，我想大概是19连胜的势头，所以我当时想，好吧，太酷了。这是一支在末段有所磕绊但已经脱胎换骨的球队。随着即将到来的NCAA锦标赛的休息期，他们会把状态调整好的。TCU说，不，今年是属于我们的年份。我们要乘风破浪。
We're the dark horse here. And just shout out to that program. Like you said, just turning things around. It was a historic season. You know, you look at all the starters they had, like what it was like 21 seasons at 12 different schools combined. It was their first season together. It was the greatest turnaround that we have seen.
我们是这里的黑马。向那个项目致敬。正如你所说，扭转了局面。这是一个创造历史的赛季。你知道，看看他们所有的首发球员，比如总共在12所不同的学校里有大约21个赛季的经验。这是他们在一起的第一个赛季。这是我们见过的最伟大的咸鱼翻身。
They were 26 wins better than, you know, when Mark Campbell took it over two years ago and you're here at the Elite Eight, like you can't ask for anything better. And just shout out to Haley Van Lyth for being so vulnerable throughout this entire journey, sharing her story, because the internet and social media was not nicer. Like, let's be so for real.
他们比两年前马克·坎贝尔（Mark Campbell）接手时多赢了26场比赛，而且你现在站上了精英八强赛的舞台，你真的不能要求更多了。向海莉·范利斯致敬，感谢她在整个旅程中展现出的脆弱与真实，分享她的故事，因为互联网和社交媒体可一点都不善良。说真的，我们现实一点吧。
And at the end of the day, she is a human. At the end of the day, yes, this is basketball, but like these are 18 to 22 year old women, young women. And I'm just so proud of her, of how she's been able to just rewrite her story. It is not done yet. It's been so cool to see like, you know, who she is as a person and how she leans on her faith. And how TCU just poured into her. Like, she was the perfect piece at the right time. And I'm so glad that she got to experience that. For sure. Such a great story for Hailey Van Leth. And on the other side of that coin, though, for Notre Dame,
归根结底，她是一个人。归根结底，是的，这是篮球，但这些是18到22岁的女性，年轻女性。我为她感到骄傲，为她如何能够改写自己的故事感到骄傲。这一切还没有结束。看到她作为一个人是什么样的，以及她如何依靠自己的信仰，这真的很酷。还有TCU是如何全力支持她的。就像，她在正确的时间成为了完美的拼图。我很高兴她能经历这一切。肯定的。对于海莉·范利斯来说，这是一个多么棒的故事。而在硬币的另一面，对于圣母大学来说，
whoo, rough, rough shooting night for their superstars. Hannah Hidalgo, Sonia Citron, Olivia Miles, I would say is their big three. They go 10 for 44 from the field. You're not going to win a lot of games like that. I think it was shot selection. I think it was lack of ball movement. It just didn't, it wasn't the Notre Dame that at one point was the best team in the country.
呜，对他们的超级巨星来说，这是一个糟糕、糟糕的投篮之夜。汉娜·伊达戈（Hannah Hidalgo）、索尼娅·西特龙（Sonia Citron）、奥利维亚·迈尔斯（Olivia Miles），可以说是他们的大三巨头。他们全场投篮44投10中。带着这样的表现，你是不可能赢得很多比赛的。我认为是投篮选择的问题。我认为是缺少球权转移的问题。那根本不是曾经一度是全国最佳球队的圣母大学。
So it was disappointing. I do think that season as a whole, for them not being in the final four, not being in the championship game is an under performance for that whole team. And Olivia Miles had a decision to make. She was number two projected pick in the WNBA draft. Seattle Storm could be heard crying if you really listen.
所以这令人失望。我确实认为就整个赛季而言，对他们没有进入四强、没有进入冠军赛来说，整支球队的表现是低于预期的。而奥利维亚·迈尔斯面临着一个抉择。她是WNBA选秀中预期的第二顺位新秀。如果你仔细听的话，西雅图风暴队（Seattle Storm）可能会在哭泣。
Because they traded, they were like, yes, this is our player. And Olivia Miles said, no, I'm not only not coming to the WNBA, but I am entering the transfer portal. Autumn, where were you when this news broke? Because I know that I screenshotted this so fast and sent it to my husband with red sirens, like 20 red sirens. Like, did you see this?
因为他们做了交易，他们当时想，太好了，这就是我们的球员。而奥利维亚·迈尔斯却说，不，我不仅不来WNBA，而且我要进入转会门户（transfer portal）了。奥特姆，当这个消息爆出时你在哪里？因为我知道我以最快的速度截屏并发给了我老公，配上了红色警报，大约20个红色警报。就像，你看到这个了吗？
I can't even send this as a DM. I am texting this to you because what? I was shook. Shook. I was on the plane so I couldn't scream. Thankfully, I had my Wi-Fi turned on because I wouldn't have gotten it until I got off the plane. So I was locked in. You know, when it dropped down, it was like, oh, she foregoed there, her WNBA draft, that
我甚至都不能把这个当成私信发送。我正在给你发短信，因为什么？我当时惊呆了。震惊。我在飞机上，所以没法尖叫。谢天谢地，我打开了Wi-Fi，否则我得下飞机后才能收到消息。所以我当时全神贯注。你知道的，当消息弹出来的时候，就像是，哦，她放弃了，她的WNBA选秀，那个
part. And I'm like, okay, cool. Like, like she's going to come back for another year. And I saw a transfer portal. I wanted to scream. I was like, what? I think that's the part that's so shocking. Like, okay, cool.
部分。然后我想，哦，酷。就像，她要回来再打一年。然后我看到了转会门户。我想尖叫。我当时想，什么？我认为这就是让人如此震惊的部分。就像，好吧，太酷了。
Like she wants to come back. Didn't end off on the note that she wanted to. Has the perfect pieces around her for a championship run. Niel Ivey is like an iconic coach that has turned, just kept the ball rolling after the Muffin McBraw era. This team has everything. And it's Notre Dame. Like she has started there.
就像她想回来一样。没有以她想要的方式结束。身边有完美的拼图来冲击总冠军。妮尔·伊维（Niel Ivey）就像是一位标志性的教练，在穆芬·麦格罗（Muffet McGraw）时代之后，让球队保持了强劲的发展势头。这支球队拥有一切。而且这是圣母大学。就像她是从那里开始的。
You look at players and it's like, okay, they're gonna start and finish there. They are Notre Dame through and through. But this one shook me because of that reason. Like I thought she was gonna start and finish there and just with everything around her, she was gonna end her final chapter there. So that's why it shook me.
你看看球员们，就会觉得，好吧，他们会从那里开始并从那里结束。他们是彻头彻尾的圣母大学人。但这个消息让我震惊，正是因为这个原因。因为我以为她会从那里开始并从那里结束，带着她身边的一切，她会在那里结束她的最后一章。这就是为什么它让我震惊。
Crazy. Crazy. Wild. Woo. Last thing I'll say on this before we move on is, you know, we were all excited coming into this season on how Hannah Hidalgo and Olivia Miles were going to play with each other. And I think a lot of people forget
太疯狂了。太疯狂了。太野了。呜。在我们继续之前，我要说的最后一件事是，你知道的，进入这个赛季时，我们都很兴奋地看到汉娜·伊达戈和奥利维亚·迈尔斯将如何一起打球。我想很多人都忘了
that it was Olivia Miles Miles team by herself before. And then she got injured. And then it was Hannah Hidalgo's team by herself for a season. And then it was like, yay, we're coming together. We're going to see this. And they're so young, so we could possibly see this for multiple years.
在此之前，这曾经是奥利维亚·迈尔斯自己的球队。然后她受伤了。然后有一个赛季，这是汉娜·伊达戈自己的球队。然后就像是，耶，我们要聚到一起了。我们要见证这个了。而且他们还那么年轻，所以我们很可能会看到这种组合持续好几年。
I don't know. I don't want to speculate. I have no idea. I don't have any reports of what's going on behind the scenes. It could be personal, it could not be. It could be that there's not enough basketballs. It could not be.
我不知道。我不想妄加猜测。我完全不知道。我没有关于幕后情况的任何报道。可能是私事，也可能不是。可能是因为篮球不够分。也可能不是。
I just know that both of those players are really, really good, and we got to see it shake out together. But now what excites me is that this is going to continue this parody conversation and that now it's not this front-loaded, you know, back court on one team, but now Olivia Miles is gonna go to another team and immediately make them better.
我只知道这两名球员真的、真的很优秀，我们得以看到她们联手。但现在让我兴奋的是，这将延续关于实力均衡的讨论，现在不再是那种把后场天赋全部堆积在一支球队的情况，而是奥利维亚·迈尔斯将前往另一支球队并立即让他们变得更好。
Or she's going to go to another team and she is going to be the superstar all on her own. But we know what she can do. So it's not like she's going somewhere else to prove anything. We already know that she's a baller. She just maybe has one other year and wants to see what's out there. I can't wait. And she'll still be a top pick for the WNBA next year.
或者她会去另一支球队，她将独自成为超级巨星。但我们知道她能做到什么。所以她不是去其他地方证明什么的。我们已经知道她是个球星了。她可能只是还有一年大学时光，想看看外面有什么。我等不及了。而且她明年仍然会是WNBA的顶级新秀。
Absolutely. Absolutely. Can't wait to when we get on with these microphones and when she announces where she goes, which, by the way, is happening very quickly. They are entering the portal and they're making decisions. And I have no idea where she's going either. Like, I'm trying to think, okay, where would she go?
绝对的。绝对的。等我们拿着这些麦克风，等她宣布去哪里的时候，我简直等不及了——顺便说一下，这发生得非常快。他们正在进入转会门户并做出决定。我也不知道她要去哪里。就像，我在想，好吧，她会去哪儿？
And I don't know. I'm like, who needs a point card? NIL, there's so much. I have no idea. Okay, last one of the roundups real quick, because it was pretty quickly and obvious. UConn as a number two seed playing against the USC team was a number one seed, but like we mentioned before, Juju Watkins, their superstar, goes down with an ACL injury in the round of 32. So this was a USC team that had to kind of make the impossible happen and go up against not just any team, but a UConn team that is playing really,
我不知道。我在想，谁需要一个控球后卫？NIL（姓名、形象和肖像权收益），有太多的因素了。我毫无头绪。好吧，快速回顾最后一场比赛，因为这相当迅速且显而易见。康涅狄格大学作为二号种子对阵一号种子的南加州大学（USC），但正如我们之前提到的，他们的超级巨星朱朱·沃特金斯（Juju Watkins）在三十二强赛中十字韧带撕裂（ACL injury）。所以这是一支不得不创造不可能奇迹的USC，要面对的不仅是随便哪支球队，而是一支状态正佳、
really well, firing on all cylinders with a Paige Becker who's playing out of her brain right now. The UConn ends up winning 78 to 64 over USC, and they advance to their 24th Final Four. So we're talking about other teams where, oh, it's been so long. UConn is like, yeah, yeah, yeah, this is the standard. Actually, this isn't even the standard.
火力全开、佩奇·贝克斯（Paige Bueckers）目前状态爆棚的康涅狄格大学。最终康涅狄格大学以78比64战胜USC，晋级她们的第24次四强。所以我们在谈论其他球队时会说，哦，已经好久没进去了。康涅狄格则是：对，对，对，这就是标准。实际上，这甚至还不是标准。
This is just one step to go to the championship, which is the standard. Actually, this isn't even the standard. This is just one step to go to the championship, which is the standard for us. But Pagebeckers, whoo! You are a baller. 31 points, nine of 18 shooting for this time. She had a 40 piece the game before that, and another 30 piece the game before that. The last player to have three games in a row with 30 points. Do you know who it was?
这只是通往总冠军的一步，而总冠军才是标准。实际上，这甚至还不是标准。这只是通往总冠军的一步，对我们来说总冠军才是标准。但是佩奇·贝克斯，呜！你真是一个球星。在这场比赛中砍下31分，18投9中。她在上一场比赛中砍下了40分，再上一场比赛又砍下了30分。上一位连续三场比赛砍下30分的球员。你知道是谁吗？
Paige Becker herself. Yes. She's her. Our freshman season. Like come on. So we know what Paige can do. She is so, so good. But Autumn, I also want you to talk about Sarah Strong
佩奇·贝克斯本人。是的。她就是她。我们的大一赛季。拜托。所以我们知道佩奇能做到什么。她真的、真的很棒。但是奥特姆，我还想让你谈谈萨拉·斯特朗（Sarah Strong）
and how the freshmen came into this game knowing that she did not have great outings the games before. But this was her first tournament. She was in high school last year. People forget she's only a freshman. How does she just turn the gas all the way up in this game? Not only that, but to have that mind shift and confidence
以及这位大一新生是如何带着对前几场比赛发挥不佳的觉悟进入这场比赛的。但这是她的锦标赛首秀。她去年还在读高中。人们忘了她只是一名大一新生。她是如何在这场比赛中彻底火力全开的？不仅如此，还要有那种心态上的转变和自信，
knowing that you're going up against a lottery picking Kiki Area Finn too, to battle against her and still have that same dominant performance is unheard of for a freshman. And Sarah Strong continuously night in and night out provides such a consistent effort that just has you in awe. Like we're like, wait a minute in another life, is she a freshman? Like what?
知道自己要对阵状元秀热门基基·里亚芬（Kiki Iriafen），与她对抗却依然能打出同样统治级的表现，这对于一个大一新生来说简直闻所未闻。萨拉·斯特朗夜复一夜地持续提供着如此稳定的表现，让人叹为观止。就像我们在想，等一下，在另一个平行时空里，她真的只是一名大一新生吗？什么鬼？
This girl is special and you see, you know, her parents and everything where she came from, like, like obviously that's been built in her. It's in her DNA, but she's going to be something special. Yes, Paige Becker's is about to leave, but you have Sarah Strong, who is coming in, knocking down threes. She's so versatile, like the spin move she had, just the composure, the body control. She is one of one and she does everything, just like the little things that sometimes don't even show up in the box score as well. Her efficiency, her consistency, her ability to like work off the dribble or footwork. It's unmatched and it's just going to be really exciting to see that. Okay, this
这个女孩很特别，你看到了，你知道的，她的父母以及她成长的地方，很显然这一切都是融入在她骨子里的。这在她的基因里，但她将成为一个特别的存在。是的，佩奇·贝克斯就要离开了，但你拥有萨拉·斯特朗，她正在加入球队，命中三分。她太全能了，比如她的转身动作，那种沉着冷静，身体控制力。她是独一无二的，她无所不能，就像那些有时甚至不会显示在数据统计表上的小细节。她的效率、她的稳定性、她通过运球或脚步创造机会的能力。这是无与伦比的，看到这一点真的会让人非常兴奋。好吧，这
was your freshman year. How do you keep growing from here? Because that's scary. That is scary. She finished with 22 points and 17 rebounds plus four assists. For those that don't know, that's really good. Those are, those are really good stats. And people- Especially as a freshman. Right. People have been comparing her to Maya Moore.
只是你的大一赛季。你从这里还能如何继续成长？因为这太可怕了。这太可怕了。她全场贡献了22分和17个篮板以及4次助攻。对于那些不知道的人来说，这真的很厉害。这些是，这些都是非常棒的数据。而且人们——特别是作为大一新生。没错。人们一直在将她与玛雅·摩尔（Maya Moore）作比较。
And I see it. And that's a great comparison. That's a lot to live up to, but she's creating her own paths. She's playing her own game. She can do so many different things at 6'1", like as an undersized post. Again, any tomorrow, it doesn't matter. Like that's just built in you. Man.
我能看出来。这是一个很棒的比较。这需要达到很高的标准，但她正在开辟自己的道路。她在打自己的比赛。作为一个身材偏矮的内线球员，她在6尺1寸的身高下能做这么多不同的事情。再次强调，任何明天，这都无关紧要——这只是你天生具备的素质。天哪。
So just being the same sentence as Maya Moore. Like I'm trying to think what sentence I'm gonna same sentence as Maya Moore. Like I'm trying to think what sentence I would be in as Maya Moore. I think only if we were in the same room. Like, okay, yeah, who's all in this room? Oh, Jordan Robinson and Maya Moore. Literally, that's it. And they probably wouldn't even be next to each other in our... Then our names wouldn't even be next to each other in a sentence like that.
所以能和玛雅·摩尔相提并论。就像我在想我会和玛雅·摩尔出现在什么样的句子中。我想只有当我们在同一个房间里时。就像，好吧，是的，这个房间里都有谁？哦，乔丹·罗宾逊（Jordan Robinson）和玛雅·摩尔。真的，就只有这样。而且她们可能甚至不会在我们的……然后我们的名字甚至都不会在这样的句子中紧挨着出现。
So for Sarah Strong to be compared, I think it's because of her versatility and her efficiency. Maya Moore was a player who could get a bucket at any single spot on the floor and is a forward, but also has guard skills. You see her bringing the ball up, but then she could also post you up. And it doesn't matter.
所以萨拉·斯特朗能被拿来比较，我认为是因为她的全面性和效率。玛雅·摩尔是一个能在地板上的任何一个点得分的球员，她是一名锋线球员，但也具备后卫的技能。你看到她把球带过半场，然后她还能为你背身单打。这都无所谓。
She can score at any level. So, UConn, you are always spoiled and have a plethora of riches. And now I am so jealous that you get Sarah Strong in a UConn uniform for three more seasons, regardless of what happens this weekend. She is still going to be able to fall out for you. Real quick on USC, they tried their hardest.
她能在任何位置得分。所以，康涅狄格，你们总是被偏爱，拥有极其丰富的阵容。现在我太嫉妒了，无论这个周末发生什么，你都能在未来三个赛季里让萨拉·斯特朗身披康涅狄格的球衣。她依然能够为你大显身手。简单说一下USC，他们已经拼尽全力了。
It was going to be a huge load on freshmen. Like we talked about, maybe in Yukon's case, that was okay because the freshmen turned up, but freshmen who were used to playing the backseat to a Juju Watkins and a Kiki Iriyapin all season long were asked to do a lot. And it was a very, very heavy task, but it was actually the senior, to a Juju Watkins and a Kiki Iriyapin all season long, were asked to do a lot. And it was a very, very heavy task,
这对大一新生来说将是一个巨大的负担。正如我们所讨论的，也许对康涅狄格来说，这没问题，因为大一新生挺身而出了，但是那些整个赛季习惯于在朱朱·沃特金斯和基基·里亚芬身后打替补、扮演绿叶的大一新生的球员们，却被要求做很多事情。这是一个非常、非常重的任务，但实际上是这位老将——在整个赛季里习惯于在朱朱·沃特金斯和基基·里亚芬身后打替补、扮演绿叶的大一新生的球员们，却被要求做很多事情。这是一个非常、非常重的任务，
but it was actually the senior. It was Rhea Marshall who had such a great game for the Trojans, 23 points, 14 rebounds, seven for 12 shooting. One of her best games of her career comes in her last game of her career. So super proud for Rhea Marshall. And this USC team has to be very, very proud.
但实际上是这位老将。是雷亚·马歇尔（Rhea Marshall）为特洛伊人队打出了如此精彩的一场比赛，砍下23分、14个篮板，12投7中。她职业生涯中最好的一场比赛之一，正是在她职业生涯的最后一场比赛中到来。所以为雷亚·马歇尔感到无比骄傲。这支USC球队也应该感到非常、非常骄傲。
Juju sent a message on Instagram saying she wished she was in the building. She is so proud of her team. Just heartbreaking, but I know that this is not the end of their story. Like, they have really solid pieces to get them back here. Yes, they had the number one freshman class come in. This is now the place to be that Juju has kind of like, not even kind of, she has just rejuvenized this program and what she was able to do in her freshman year, carried over to her sophomore year, just praying that
朱朱在Instagram上发了一条消息，说她真希望自己能在现场。她为自己的球队感到无比骄傲。虽然令人心碎，但我知道这并不是他们故事的结局。就像，他们拥有非常坚实的阵容能够让他们重返这里。是的，他们迎来了排名第一的大一新生班底。这里现在成了人们向往的地方，因为朱朱已经——甚至不仅是“某种程度上”，她已经让这个项目重新焕发了生机，她在自己大一赛季所做到的一切，延续到了大二赛季，只祈祷
she comes back stronger and healthier than ever, which she will. Just the human element of it, again, like she is a human. She loves basketball. Basketball is her everything. So you just, you just pray for her during this time, hoping that she's well and just taking time for herself because it is a long process. But it was really cool to see like her teammates step up for her every single way. Like the shirts, the Funko Pop, like everything about it was just incredible teammates. But again, they're not done. They're still writing their story. Juju is so young, this freshman class will have a year of experience under their belt.
她能以比以往更强大、更健康的姿态归来，她一定会的。从人性的角度来看，再次强调，她是一个人。她热爱篮球。篮球就是她的一切。所以在这个时期，你只能为她祈祷，希望她一切都好，并花时间好好照顾自己，因为这是一个漫长的过程。但看到她的队友们在方方面面为她挺身而出，真的很酷。比如球衣、Funko Pop（摇头娃娃）、所有这些细节，都展现出他们是不可思议的队友。但话说回来，他们还没有结束。他们仍在书写自己的故事。朱朱还很年轻，这个大一新生班底将带着一年的经验继续前行。
And the transfer portal is alive and well, so who knows what pieces they'll grab. Sure is. Whoo! Alive and well. And I think people are gonna want to come and play with Juju. I think that's also what's on full display. Shout out to Funko Pop getting all this free promotion. Maybe it wasn't free, maybe they paid for it,
而且转会门户运作得如火如荼，所以谁知道他们会签下什么样的强援呢。确实如此。呜！如火如荼。而且我认为人们会想来和朱朱一起打球。我认为这也是充分展现出来的一点。向获得所有这些免费宣传的Funko Pop致敬。也许这不是免费的，也许他们付过钱了，
but man, we know what a Juju Funko Pop looks like. And the bun, maybe it's a bobblehead, but the bun still did not move. I loved it. I love it so much. Edges and all. Never does. I love it. Okay, we're gonna take a break
但是天哪，我们都知道朱朱的Funko Pop长什么样。还有那个发髻，也许是个摇头娃娃，但那个发髻依然纹丝不动。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。发际线什么的。从来没变过。我太喜欢了。好吧，我们要休息一下，
and we'll be right back to talk our predictions for the Final Four on the way back. Welcome back to the Women's Hoop Show. Final Four, Final Four. I can't believe that it is here. I can't believe that it is here. I can't believe that it is here. I can't believe that it is here.
马上回来讨论我们对四强的预测。欢迎回到女子篮球秀（Women's Hoop Show）。四强，四强。我简直不敢相信它终于来了。我简直不敢相信它终于来了。我简直不敢相信它终于来了。我简直不敢相信它终于来了。
I can't believe that it is here. I can't believe that it is here. I can't believe that it is here. Welcome back to the Women's Hoop Show. Final Four. Final Four. I can't believe that it is here. March was a very long month, but it is now over. And it is April. And if you make it through the trenches of March, then you get to get to Tampa in April.
我简直不敢相信它终于来了。我简直不敢相信它终于来了。我简直不敢相信它终于来了。欢迎回到女子篮球秀。四强。四强。我简直不敢相信它终于来了。三月是一个非常漫长的月份，但它现在已经结束了。已经是四月了。如果你能熬过三月的艰难险阻，那么你就能在四月抵达坦帕。
And that is where we are headed. Games are Friday and the championship game is on Sunday coming up. But let's go through these and give our one thing that we would look out for. If you are watching these games, as you should, you better. Here's the thing that you should be watching. So let's start with South Carolina and Texas. Both number one seeds. They're going up against each other for another time. This is gonna be number four, right?
这就是我们要去的地方。比赛在周五进行，冠军赛将在随后的周日举行。但让我们过一遍这些比赛，说出我们各自会关注的一个看点。如果你在看这些比赛——正如你理应做的那样，你最好去看。以下是你应该关注的看点。所以让我们从南卡罗来纳和德克萨斯开始。两支都是一号种子。他们将再次交手。这将是第四次对决，对吧？
Yes, number four. That they played each other. Fourth time they played each other. Whoo! And South Carolina is winning that three wins or two wins to one for Texas. Got him one time. What is Autumn Johnson? Your one thing that you will be looking in this matchup defense for both teams. Both teams play sound defense. And when you look at South Carolina in particular, trying to run it back, it's going to have to be, you know, coming down to trying to clog the paint with Texas.
是的，第四次。他们交手过。第四次交手。呜！南卡罗来纳赢得了其中的三场胜利，或者说德克萨斯赢了一场、南卡赢了两场。德克萨斯赢过他们一次。奥特姆·约翰逊，你在这场对决中会关注的一个看点是什么？两支球队的防守。两支球队都打着稳健的防守。当你特别看看南卡罗来纳时，他们想要卫冕，这归根结底将不得不落脚于，你知道的，试图用防守堵住德克萨斯的内线。
I mean, they have a lot of size, their guards try to attack the rim or get in the mid range. It's all going to be about neutralizing the size and side and clogging the paint. So for me, it comes down to that. And if you compare that with some offense, all teams, like we just mentioned it, Texas, not really being big on the three ball, but South Carolina as well struggling beyond the arc. So I think that's going to be the difference maker. That's so good. I love when teams know each other so well and they're just going to be like, OK, we can scheme, we can scheme, we can scheme.
我的意思是，他们有很多身高优势，他们的后卫试图冲击篮筐或进入中距离。这一切都将关乎如何化解对手的身高优势并堵塞油漆区。所以对我来说，关键就在于此。如果你把这一点与进攻进行对比，所有的球队，就像我们刚才提到的那样，德克萨斯不太擅长投三分，但南卡罗来纳在远投方面也举步维艰。所以我认为这将是决定胜负的关键。太棒了。我喜欢当两支球队对彼此如此了解时，他们就会想：“好吧，我们可以制定战术，我们可以制定战术，我们可以制定战术。”
We can watch game film of ourselves playing against them and what went wrong, what went right. But at the end of the day, to me, it's going to come down who wants it more. I know that's a little generic, but based off of what I said about South Carolina earlier, who wants it? I want people diving on the floor.
我们可以观看我们与他们交手的比赛录像，看看哪里出了问题，哪里做对了。但归根结底，在我看来，这将取决于谁的求胜欲更强。我知道这有点老套，但基于我之前对南卡罗来纳的看法，谁更渴望胜利？我希望看到球员们飞身扑向地板拼抢。
I want box outs on the floor. I want box outs every possession. I think this is going to come down to a possession, maybe a few possessions, but that's... Also, both of these teams, this is gonna be another low scoring game. If you want offense, maybe this isn't the matchup for you because this is going to be a low grinded out game,
我希望看到每一次进攻都有卡位抢篮板。我认为这场比赛将取决于某一次球权，也许是几次球权，但这……同样，这两支球队，这将是又一场低比分比赛。如果你想看进攻，也许这场比赛不适合你，因为这将是一场艰难的拉锯战，
which is really fun, especially at the final four level. Okay. Love it. Love it. Next one is UCLA, a number one seed, the number one overall team going up against a number two seed in UConn. This is the first NCAA Final Four appearance for UCLA. They did win a championship in the NAIAW
这真的很有趣，尤其是在四强赛的级别上。好吧。太棒了。太棒了。下一场是UCLA，一号种子、全国头号球队，对阵二号种子康涅狄格大学。这是UCLA历史上第一次打进NCAA四强。他们确实在NAIAW（美国女子大学篮球协会前身）赢得过冠军，
with Anne Myers-Driesdale, just have to throw that in there. But for UConn, we mentioned it, they're 24th. So you have this program, if you have the whole program on your back for both of these teams, one key as you are watching this game, UCLA versus UConn. Yes.
由安·迈尔斯-德赖斯代尔（Anne Myers-Driesdale）率领，我必须顺便提一句。但对于康涅狄格来说，正如我们提到的，这是他们的第24次。所以对于这两支球队来说，当整个项目的期待都压在你的肩上时，当你观看这场UCLA对阵康涅狄格的比赛时，有一个关键点。是的。
I spoke to Paige Becker and I asked her what separates teams from the Sweet 16 and Elite 8 to break into the Final Four. And she said you have to be connected. And I trust her with everything because she has got her team to a final four every single year she has played. And UConn's one of the most connected, efficient teams. They go in with the one and O mentality. UCLA has been preaching the same thing, not getting ahead and making the moment too big.
我采访了佩奇·贝克斯，我问她是什么让球队从甜蜜十六强（Sweet 16）和精英八强中脱颖而出闯入四强的。她说你必须保持凝聚力。我完全信任她，因为她打过的每一年的大学篮球都把她的球队带进了四强。康涅狄格是极具凝聚力、最高效的球队之一。他们带着“1比0”的心态进入比赛。UCLA一直以来也在宣扬同样的理念，不要想得太远，不要把比赛压力放大。
But if I can add in a bonus key, you got to neutralize both stars. Like Lauren Betts has been going off, Page Becker has been on a tangent. You have to neutralize the stars if you're looking at both respective teams. That's what it comes down to. Are they going to be able to cancel each other out? They might cancel each other out at 30, but are they going to be able to cancel each other out? Lauren Betts versus Page Becker, they don't guard each other.
但如果我可以补充一个额外的关键点，你必须限制双方的球星。就像劳伦·贝茨（Lauren Betts）状态火热，佩奇·贝克斯也正处于巅峰状态。如果你看看这两支球队，你必须限制对方的球星。关键就在这里。她们能互相抵消吗？她们可能会在30分的水平上互相抵消，但她们能互相限制吗？劳伦·贝茨对阵佩奇·贝克斯，她们不防守彼此。
They don't play the same position. So it's gonna still be a team effort. But I'm very curious if Gino watched that last game, sees Lauren Betts on the bench for a whole quarter, and he says, let's see if the rest of UCLA can do it again. We know that Lauren Betts is consistent. Let's try to get her in foul trouble early, see if she has to sit again, and if Gabriella Hawke scores 18 points
她们不打同一个位置。所以这仍然需要团队的努力。但我很好奇吉诺（Gino Auriemma）是否观看了上一场比赛，看到劳伦·贝茨整整一节坐在替补席上，然后他说，让我们看看UCLA的其他人是否能再次做到这一点。我们知道劳伦·贝茨很稳定。让我们试着让她早早陷入犯规麻烦，看看她是否不得不再次坐在场下，以及加布里埃拉·哈克（Gabriella Jaquez）是否能再次砍下18分。
again. If Tamiya Gardner, like we are going to make that bet to see if the others show up again. I would be curious to see if that is a game plan that he rides with. But either way, I love what you said, neutralize the superstars. Good luck with that. Glad I'm not gonna be out there. You can't stop them. Just neutralize them. You can't stop them. Just try to slow them down.
如果塔米娅·加德纳（Talia von Oelhoffen / 译者注：原文口误或指代其他球员）——就像我们会打这个赌，看看其他人是否会再次站出来。我很想知道这是否是他会执行的比赛计划。但无论如何，我喜欢你所说的，限制超级巨星。祝你好运。很高兴我不用上场。你无法阻止她们。只能去限制她们。你无法阻止她们。只能试着放慢她们的速度。
Just try to slow them down. I love it. Okay, before we leave, this is a little bit of a tricky one. Let's power rank these final four teams based off of number one, you would be least surprised if they win the title, to number four, that would be super, super surprising if they win it. I feel like this is hard because we just said any of these teams could win it, but what is your ranking as I think about?
只能试着放慢她们的速度。我喜欢。好吧，在我们离开之前，这是一个有点棘手的问题。让我们根据以下标准对这四支四强球队进行实力排名：从第一名——如果你夺冠，你会最不感到惊讶；到第四名——如果你夺冠，会超级、超级让人惊讶。我觉得这很难，因为我们刚才说过任何这些球队都有可能夺冠，但在我思考时，你的排名是怎样的？
OK, I see what you're doing here. Let me go quick. No. OK, so one, UConn. Obviously, the way they've been playing their victory is super efficient. Azee Fudge, she did have a rough game last time, but like, I don't expect that going back to back. Two, I'm gonna say UCLA. Ooh! Oh gosh.
好吧，我明白你在做什么了。让我快点说。不。好吧，所以第一名，康涅狄格。很明显，他们近期的打法和胜利都超级高效。阿兹·富兹（Azzi Fudd），她上场比赛确实手感不佳，但是，我不期望这种糟糕表现会连续发生两次。第二名，我要选UCLA。噢！天哪。
But, all right. I like it. Hold on, actually, no, no, no, no, no, no. Okay, see, that's, the middle of the pack is hard because do you do South Carolina? That is hard. Do you do South Carolina or UCLA? Because honestly, I feel like the only reason I put South Carolina at three is because they've
但是，好吧。我喜欢。等一下，其实，不，不，不，不，不，不。好吧，你看，中间梯队很难抉择，因为你要把南卡罗来纳排进去吗？这很难。你选南卡罗来纳还是UCLA？因为老实说，我觉得我把南卡罗来纳排在第三的唯一原因是因为他们
been scaring me. I'm just going to be honest. That's fair. This is fair. We are the same so far. That's the only reason. There's too many close calls, Maryland, Indiana, and now Duke, like at some point where, where does it break? And that's what scares me.
一直让我感到害怕。我只是实话实说。这很公平。这很公平。到目前为止我们的看法是一样的。这就是唯一的理由。有太多次险象环生了，对阵马里兰、印第安纳，现在又是杜克，就像在某个时刻，防线会在哪里崩塌？这就是让我害怕的地方。
Yeah. And then for Texas, they don't hurt you offensively as much. And if South Carolina figures it out, they can on both ends. But again, other teams have to score, like we said, versus TCU, they flustered them. Their defense has always been their solid foundation and that can help you win championships. They're a great rebounding team as well. So that could give them the edge,
是的。然后对于德克萨斯来说，他们在进攻端对你的杀伤没有那么大。如果南卡罗来纳找到了状态，他们可以在攻防两端都打得很好。但话又说回来，正如我们所说，对阵TCU时，其他球队必须得分，他们让对手方寸大乱。他们的防守一直是他们坚实的基石，这可以帮助你赢得总冠军。他们也是一支伟大的篮板球球队。所以这可能会给他们带来优势，
but they're gonna have to go up and get South Carolina who has seen them for the fourth time. All right. I agree with you. I agree. I was going through that with you. We have UConn, UCLA, South Carolina, Texas. I agree.
但他们必须迎战已经第四次面对他们的南卡罗来纳。好吧。我同意你的看法。我同意。我刚刚一直在和你一起梳理。我们有康涅狄格、UCLA、南卡罗来纳、德克萨斯。我同意。
I think Texas would have to have an incredible shooting night to be able to, two shooting nights to be able to win it all at the end. Not saying that they can't, but I think they have the hardest climb so far. But we said that about Texas getting out of this hard bracket. And they did it. They are here and they made it to the Final Four.
我认为德克萨斯必须打出两次不可思议的投篮之夜，才能最终赢得总冠军。并不是说他们做不到，但我认为他们目前的攀登之路是最艰难的。但我们对德克萨斯从这个艰难的赛区突围时也是这么说的。他们做到了。他们在这里，他们杀入了四强。
It doesn't matter. These are going to be really, really great games. It is only Tuesday. I wish it was Friday immediately because then they would be on my TV screen. But this was so much fun. Autumn, I can't wait for you to be on vacation after all of this because you deserve it.
没关系。这些将会是非常非常精彩的比赛。今天才星期二。我希望立刻就是星期五，因为那样它们就会在我的电视屏幕上了。但这太有趣了。奥秋，我迫不及待地想让你在这一切结束后去度假，因为这是你应得的。
You've been working, my friend. So have you. Booked and busy. Booked, busy and blessed. Booked and busy. We are both in hotel rooms right now. I'm in Dallas, you're in Tampa, but I'll be joining you in Tampa in a few days
我的朋友，你一直在努力工作。你也是。行程满满，忙碌不停。行程满满、忙碌且幸福。行程满满又忙碌。我们现在都在酒店房间里。我在达拉斯，你在坦帕，但我几天后就会去坦帕和你汇合
because that's where the party's gonna be at and that's where the good basketball is. Thank you, Autumn, this was so fun and happy Final Four to you. Happy Final Four to all. I can't wait to see you. Safe travels here and this is fun. It's always fun.
因为派对将在那里举行，精彩的篮球比赛也在那里。谢谢你，奥秋，这太有趣了，祝你终极四强赛快乐。祝大家终极四强赛快乐。我迫不及待地想见到你。祝你旅途平安，这真的很开心。这总是很有趣。
It's always a vibe. Yay! The Women's Hoop Show is an Odyssey original podcast hosted by me, Jordan Robinson. Today, our co-host was Autumn Johnson. Our producer is Phil Swietek. Our video team is led by Kirk Courtney and includes Tim Meikle, Evan Cox, Allison Jeffrey, and Lauren Vieira. Our executive producers are Greg Holtzman, Asha Saluja, Danny Friesinger, Maddie Sprunkizer and Leah Reese Dennis.
这总是充满氛围感。耶！《女子篮球秀》（The Women's Hoop Show）是奥德赛（Audyssey）原创播客，由我——乔丹·鲁宾逊（Jordan Robinson）主持。今天我们的联合主持人是奥秋·约翰逊（Autumn Johnson）。我们的制作人是菲尔·斯维泰克（Phil Swietek）。我们的视频团队由柯克·考特尼（Kirk Courtney）领导，成员包括蒂姆·迈克尔（Tim Meikle）、埃文·考克斯（Evan Cox）、艾莉森·杰弗里（Allison Jeffrey）和劳伦·维埃拉（Lauren Vieira）。我们的执行制作人是格雷格·霍尔茨曼（Greg Holtzman）、阿莎·萨卢贾（Asha Saluja）、丹尼·弗里辛格（Danny Friesinger）、麦迪·斯普伦基泽（Maddie Sprunkizer）和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。
And special thanks to Moira Karan and Josephina Francis. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
特别感谢莫伊拉·卡兰（Moira Karan）和约瑟芬娜·弗朗西斯（Josephina Francis）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。